The game is gone!
One second.
Where'd it go?
Oh!
There it is.
Wait.
One second.
There we go.
Okaerina saimase!
Kusutin-sama!
Ocho-sama!
And lawnmower Nancy Drew-sama!
Hello, everybody.
Howdy.
Howdy doody.
Welcome in.
Welcome back to Nancy Drew!
Nancy Drew.
Speedy Fire!
Thank you so much for the vibe.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Found out about you through the Nancy Drew game fan community.
Uh-oh.
Did they know I'm playing this?
I didn't... wait.
Wow.
Oh, thank you!
Thanks for dropping by!
Thank you, thank you.
There's a community.
They're talking about me.
Scary.
Wow!
Thank you!
Work is ultra crazy today.
Listening to the game has been really helping me get through.
Thank you so much.
I'm glad you liked the cover.
Did you guys listen to the cover?
Did you guys?
I just shared your first stream on our Nancy Drew.
Well...
Thank you!
Thank you very much!
Thank you so much for the 20 gifted!
Yeah, if you didn't know, I put out a cover...
Two days ago.
Oh, can't say goodbye to yesterday from Metal Gear Solid 2.
And even if you're like, I'm not a fan of Metal Gear or Metal Gear Solid 2.
I still think you should listen to it because I think it's a pretty song.
And you don't have to know anything about Metal Gear Solid 2 to know anything about it too!
True crew!
Thank you, Foxeye for the super job!
Thank you!
Trillions must listen to the cover.
I don't know, it's one of those songs that was more like a...
Hot dog!
Hot dad!
No, not like that.
More like a... it was like a...
It's like a passion thing for me, you know?
Rather than like a...
Oh, I hope this gets lots and lots of views.
But also, I hope it gets lots and lots of views.
Because, you know, if maybe ever a certain company is like...
Man, do we want to work with VTubers?
For promotion of a certain...
Um...
Bleddle...
Bler...
Blawlet game?
Then...
They might be like...
Oh, wow!
She has...
She has so many views!
So...
Also...
I did that whole song in one take.
So...
Yeah!
I...
I did it all!
There were so many Super Chats.
Hold on.
I have to like exit out of the game...
To be able to read them.
Um...
So...
It's...
If I miss your Super Chats today...
I'm very sorry.
Because otherwise...
I can't...
I have to like exit out of the game...
To scroll up...
To read them.
Thank you for bringing a Meow Tower.
Oh, yeah!
I love Meow...
Meow Tower!
I finally finished all my little cats rooms.
Now I'm just playing for fun...
And collecting tuna cans.
Thanks to our girl!
Cody, thank you!
Is Nancy Drew trying to find you?
Is this a Minto ghost mystery?
Hmm...
Oh, she's trying to find...
I'm scarier than this ghost, obviously.
Thank you, Spike!
BabyCore, thank you for the five gifted!
Jessie, thank you for the five gifted!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
My Minto, it's my birthday.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Kaya Moon, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Alright.
I think I'm all cut out.
I'm also obsessed with Meow Tower.
Thanks to you.
I know, it's really...
It's such like a good...
Idol game.
Like, just to be...
Good evening, Fred!
Oh, you saw the Koyo!
I forgot to retweet it earlier.
I will do it after stream.
I have so many things to tweet.
But I kind of like to try and space things out.
I got a tweet about the mug.
I got a tweet about Koyo.
Hmm.
But then I also got busy today because I was like...
I was...
Working on stuff.
Ducky, thanks for the gifted!
Koyo.
Yeah, Koyo from Kimono Friends.
She asked if I wanted to...
Do a small little dance cover with her.
And...
I collabed with her.
I collabed with her...
A couple weeks ago now.
Hello, Nanograms.
Thank you for the app wreck.
Of course!
Um...
She's so small!
She's so small.
She was just like...
I...
She was like, how tall are you?
And I was like, you know...
149.
She was like...
Oh...
Cause I guess she's...
You know, she's a coyote.
She doesn't know how tall she is.
Maybe.
She was like...
Staff said that I was this size with my ears.
But I don't think they're right.
I look so small next to you.
She...
She's itty bitty!
A little coyote!
I mean, coyotes are quite small.
Even for dogs, so...
But, um...
Yeah, we collabed a couple weeks ago.
But actually...
Koyo and I have known each other for...
Quite a while now, so...
Um...
We've been friends for...
Quite a long time.
Um...
Actually...
I'm more...
Well, to me...
I say we're friends, but to me, I'm a fan of her.
I've been a fan of her.
I think she's just the cutest stinking thing.
So...
Yeah, I'm glad that...
And she's graduating soon.
So I'm glad that we could dance together.
We've...
We've like...
We've gone to like...
Like, Matsuri together.
We've gone to karaoke together.
So...
You know.
Just bought your indirect kiss and mug.
Thank you!
Good to give you something to look forward to every morning.
Mwah mwah mwah!
Can't wait for the new...
Mousepad t-shirt.
Now new mug.
Wookiee!
Thank you!
Oh hi, Min!
Your new cover was so beautiful.
Makes me want to try the Metal Gear series now.
Metal Gear is very...
Emotional.
You have to prepare yourself.
Well...
Hmm...
So...
Last time on...
Nancy Drew San...
Chan...
What's the...
What do they call her?
Nancy Drew Chan or...
San?
I don't remember.
I think I remember.
Oh gosh.
Okay, so basically...
Nancy Drew goes to...
The Rio Con.
Um...
And they're just like...
It's not haunted.
And then she sees a ghost in the mirror.
And she's like...
Wah!
And then...
Um...
What was the guy's name?
Starts with an R.
Right?
Oh...
Uh...
Oh gosh.
I can't remember his name.
Rentaro!
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Kojima!
Rentaro gives us...
Um...
Books of...
Sudoku.
We love that.
I also...
Can I?
Okay.
I don't think I can change my level.
I accidentally made the mistake of choosing Senior Detective.
Even though this is my first ever time playing Nancy Drew.
And...
Um...
We're about to do some really hard...
Uh...
Sudoku puzzle.
Because...
And I only know nanograms.
I don't know Sudoku.
I'm not very good with that.
We can help with the Sudoku?
Okay.
Yes, please!
Please!
Please...
Please help with Sudoku.
And because...
Uh...
There's this mechanical robot cat...
That is like...
Guarding the...
The table...
The desk...
The front desk...
That we need to...
Dis...
Disarm.
It's...
This game is so weird.
Oh, thank you so much for the raid!
Hello!
We're just getting started, so...
Hmm...
Yeah, Suki.
Suki.
Suki was the cat.
So let's, um...
I think it's this one.
I'm almost positive.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So load.
So...
We just got back to the Ryokan.
And...
This lady...
I feel like I'm giving the worst ever summary.
There's...
Okay.
There's two sisters.
Her...
And then...
The other girl...
Who works at like a bento shop.
And...
The...
Their mom passed away.
But we don't know why.
Alvin!
Thank you so much for the five gifts.
Thank you!
And...
They...
Are...
We are trying to figure out why the Ryokan is haunted.
The bento sister is the cool one.
Yeah.
Cool one.
Oh my god!
I forgot I had...
Cowboy Joe...
As my background.
Um...
Okay.
So we just got...
Hold on.
We just got...
The Sudoku book.
And we have to complete it.
Sudoku.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh wait!
You only do one at a time!
Oh that's not bad.
Okay.
So...
This can't be nine.
Oh gosh.
How are you supposed to figure this out?
I'm gonna put like...
Can I just put random for now?
How do you do this?
Like how do you do like a...
Like a placeholder?
I...
I don't know.
Like...
I...
I don't even know what the strat is.
Like I know...
I know what you're supposed to do for Sudoku but...
I don't know what like the strat is.
Made it in time for puzzles.
Oh yeah baby!
Usually you can put in all the possible numbers then cross them out.
Okay, okay, okay.
So...
This can't be four.
It can't be five.
It can't be seven.
It can't be eight.
It could be nine.
So happy you're continuing this Nancy Drew game.
I really hope you enjoy the rest of it.
Thank you Chip!
Thank you.
So now we need a one...
One...
Four...
Five...
Nine.
One...
Four...
Five...
Nine.
Let's put nine...
Oh, wait no.
Just kidding.
Wait.
One...
Four...
Five...
One...
Four...
Five.
Try solving the left column first.
It's the easiest.
Oh...
Okay, okay.
So...
It could either be three...
Or...
Five...
Nine.
Three...
Five...
Nine.
Three...
Five...
Nine.
So this is not nine.
So it's three or five.
This is not nine.
So nine is up here.
And...
Uh...
Wait.
What was it?
Three...
Or...
Five?
Could be either one.
Three can only be at the top or bottom.
Why?
The middle one can't be three?
This one?
Why not?
Three can't be in the same box.
Wait.
What do you mean?
Hmm?
There's a three in the box.
Where do you see that?
There's already a three.
Huh?
What?
Oh, it's by box?
Oh my god!
Oh!
Oh, so it's by the...
Ow!
What do you mean bent?
I told you.
I don't know the...
How...
I don't place a doku.
Okay.
So then three is down here.
It's both?
Okay.
I guess that makes it a little easier though, right?
Cause you can kind of isolate it.
Okay.
Hmm.
I...
Uh...
I'm confused.
What if I just put random...
You know?
Let's see.
This could be...
One, two, three...
Or...
Eight, one...
Five.
Eight, one, or five.
Eight...
Can't be eight here.
Can't be one here.
So maybe...
So eight would be here...
Or here.
Uh...
I'm just gonna do...
Like this.
I feel like I'm already messing it up.
You're getting it.
I'm not.
You guys, this is also...
Look at this.
This is how many we have to solve.
Maybe I should just...
Maybe I should just have you guys solve all of them for me.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh god.
We're gonna be here forever!
Ha ha ha ha.
Uh...
What if I just brute force it?
You assume we know.
You have to solve them?
Yes, this one we actually 100% have to solve.
Because it's to continue the story.
To be able to know how to...
We have to solve these so that the guy...
Here, hold on, I'll show you guys.
Wait, how do I... Get me out of here.
Get me out, get me out.
So, there's this cat here.
Uh, not there.
Hi.
Oh my god.
This cat...
We have to...
We have to be able to...
Disarm it, but we don't know how.
Hi.
I'll stop bugging you now.
Okay, see ya.
Bye-bye.
Hi.
Nani ga suki?
Choco Minto!
Yorimba-a-nata!
Oh, I'm spinning, I'm spinning.
Oh yeah, sorry.
Okay, getting dizzy.
Getting dizzy.
Alright.
No, no, no.
There we go.
Okay.
Back to Sudoku.
We have to do this.
Okay.
Oh, golly.
Guys, I have no faith.
Why couldn't it be Nonograms?
Why do you hate to skip?
I like to do all the same numbers together as a first step.
For example, you solve all ones with the current numbers.
Hmm?
Second column from the right is the new easy.
Yeah.
Well...
Easy.
Wait, so this one's gotta be six.
So one, two, and then three.
Four, five, six.
I wonder...
Hold on, let me see if it'll let us mess up.
Oh, it will!
Oh, that's messed up.
That's messed up that they'll let us mess...
They'll let us, like, they won't be like...
Come on, Nancy.
That's where you come in and be like...
I don't know about that.
Father Pickles, happy birthday!
Sorry, I'm not doing birthday songs for a little while.
Because of my throat.
But I can wish you a happy, happy birthday!
Her boy!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Alright.
Maybe on a lower difficulty, she does...
Maybe.
Maybe...
Okay.
This can't be one or two.
It might be three.
And this can't be...
Well, obviously it can't be two.
This can't be one.
Oh, gosh.
Five, three, two at top row.
Sy, I'm listening to you!
Five, three, two.
If I'm getting one guide...
So be it.
So...
Oh, it can't be three!
You're right!
So it must be...
Two!
Yeah!
And then this must be three.
It can't be two!
Here?
What are you talking about?
Oh, you're right.
I saw.
Oh, no.
Oh, guys, I already...
Oh, no!
Um...
Where did I put the...
Last one?
Wait.
Did I put three?
Many people know Nancy Drew, but have you heard of her lesser known twin, Nancy Erased?
Second row is four, five, one.
Thank you.
This is to continue the story, everybody.
I play nanograms.
I don't play Sudoku.
We must all be good in our one talent.
Wait, then two would be here.
But then I don't have a place to put one.
So I already messed up.
The column has a mistake.
Yeah, clearly.
One, six, five are incorrect in top right.
I'm literally scratching my head right now like a monkey.
Like that?
Wait, no.
Oh!
I don't want to play this anymore.
I don't like Sudoku.
I don't like Sudoku!
I don't want to play this anymore.
Ugh!
Swap one and five.
Okay.
Wait, did I do that?
Wait.
Did I swap them?
Wait, did I swap them?
I can't remember what the order was.
Chatter was wrong.
Oh.
As someone who hates Sudoku and was given a book of them for Christmas and then had that whole book solved by afternoon.
Yeah, that's you.
I...
don't like numbers.
So...
I'm gonna look it up.
Tansu drew.
Shadow at the water's edge.
Walkthrough.
Okay.
Where do we get to the Sudoku?
This must be like super...
Oh!
My senior master's Sudoku.
Okay.
Three, two...
I got the first row right!
Actually, I'm just gonna erase them all.
Five.
Watch my...
This is a...
This is a speed run, everybody.
This is for everybody who wants to know how to solve this puzzle.
This is the most difficult puzzle in the game.
By my intuition.
By my spiritual prowess.
I can see...
I can see the future, the past.
Everything that is happening.
At...
Everything that has happened.
Will happen.
Will never happen.
I am seeing it all.
I am having all the answers beamed directly into my mind.
I am being called upon.
By a higher plane.
That says here is what you must do.
Nancy Drew.
Whoa!
And then my hair flies off.
And then my underwear flies off.
And then all my body parts disintegrate.
I become nothing.
I become everything.
I become light.
I see everything.
I see.
And I feel all.
Every experience.
I've lived it.
I've died it.
Everything is happening to me.
At this very moment.
In Sudoku.
Nancy Drew.
What happened to you?
How did you become like this?
Nancy Drew.
How did you become so you?
You are so powerful.
Oops.
And you can see all.
And you never make a mistake.
Nancy Drew.
We trust you.
You are all that is real and true.
Nancy Drew.
We believe in you.
Nancy Drew never has ever done anything bad.
Or made a mistake in her life!
Ok.
Grub's bald head and tail starts squeaking.
Next one!
Oh no, you're right.
Guys, I don't usually cheat on puzzles.
Okay, I didn't go to math class in school.
And now, whenever I see numbers, I start to cry.
That's a true story.
Okay, so Nancy drew...
My Sudoku is different... than the walkthrough.
Okay, wait, I can do this one.
One, three, two, five... Oh, see, I've already solved some of it.
Six... Nope, that's an eight.
Sorry, I can't read numbers very well at all.
Please understand.
I like... I like nonograms because I make a picture.
This is just numbers and it stresses me out.
Four, nine.
Okay.
Uh, five, one, two, nine, four... I wish they give you the option to choose.
Like, do you want to do Sudoku or do you want to do nonogram?
Because why give you both books then?
If they... if it's... it feels like...
Oh yeah, I'm training you by giving you the nonogram or the Sudoku book.
Why give me both?
Why get my hopes up?
Hmm?
How do I know kanji?
Oh, I don't know kanji.
But also, I'm not gonna sit here and explain my trauma to you.
You, you, you, you, you, I don't need to explain to you.
Two, four, one.
Fair.
Can't wait for it to arrive.
Also, Minto, how are you with crosswords?
I'm not bad with... I don't know, actually.
I like crosswords.
Bought the cup.
Thank you!
Oh, someone asked about the initial, like, the original mugs.
Um...
It was in a member stream, but someone asked, like, Hey, Minto, when are we seeing the mugs?
And, uh, they should be...
Shipping out soon.
Um...
Because...
They, um...
They had a little bit of a...
A hiccup at the manufacturing.
But they should be...
I think it was, like, I was told this week, even.
So...
Um, those...
Should be on their way.
Soon!
Sorry!
I'm so stressed out.
Uh...
Okay.
What do I do with this one?
It's completely different.
Oh, no.
Okay, guys.
This one, we're gonna have to solve legitimately.
Okay?
This one...
The last one will solve legitimately.
But these ones will speed run through it.
So that we can continue the game.
I have no...
Um...
Even a little bit of...
Uh...
Shame doing this at all.
Actually.
So...
Assuming this is gonna be a full three hours Sudoku stream?
Maybe.
Sorry.
Hmm...
Uh...
And you know what...
Oops!
If you're upset about...
I...
You guys saw how good I solved all those...
No-no grams last time!
And then I'm...
Put...
Being...
Put through this?
Oops!
This is...
This is so rude!
This is just rudeness!
Six...
Four...
Two...
I...
I have...
I'm capable of other things!
But not numbers!
Oh god!
It's the creepy music!
The song is especially creepy!
Six...
Four...
Three...
Seven...
The ghost is angry that I'm trading up again!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Eight...
Nine...
One...
I wonder how many...
Oh, it's the same.
Okay, never mind.
If I were to have been in the junior one, it would have been the same...
Uh...
The same number...
Of...
Sudoku to do...
This is so messed up!
Nancy Drew, I'll never forgive you!
I'll never forgive you for making me do Sudoku!
Ugh!
Okay.
I'm gonna stop complaining...
Soon.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Okay.
Six...
Five...
Three...
Nine...
Eight...
One...
I can't even remember my own phone number, you guys!
I have to pretend that I just got a new phone number recently, and I'd be like, Oh sorry, it's a new phone number, I have to look it up!
Cause...
I...
I don't know it.
What is it?
Ha ha ha ha ha!
I can't tell you, I don't remember!
Ah ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
Would you like to look in your phone settings and click that about phone button and show me the 10 digits that are written there?
Does it play this creepy sort of ghost music everywhere or just at the ryokan?
At the ryokan, baby!
8, 7, 5, 9, 6.
We're doing it, guys!
We're doing it!
Oh, the numbers are coming to me at once!
Oh, why is 6 afraid of 7?
Why is 6 afraid of 7?
Why?
7, 8, 9!
7 is a cannibal.
And therefore...
It's terrifying.
7...
You would go to...
What was that place?
Um...
Okay!
Ah, what?
The place!
Oh my gosh!
The Ripley's, believe it or not, I went there once as a kid.
I went there once as a kid.
And...
I...
It had me believing that Hannibal Lecter was real.
Because...
They're just like, this is Hannibal Lecter's...
Uh...
His...
It's his little mouth thing.
That...
That they used to cover his mouth.
So that he wouldn't eat people.
And I'm just like...
Wait, he...
Wait, he isn't?
He's real?
He's outside my window right now?
I see you chose the ordinary.
He's based on a real serial killer.
Yeah, but I remember at the...
At the place, they were just like, this is Hannibal Lecter's.
Maybe they meant from the movie?
Like...
This is the prop they used?
I don't know.
Mintoku.
But...
I'm like...
You...
They're making me feel like he's a real person.
He's literally me.
Hannibal Lecter.
That's the not part.
Maybe it was the actual prop.
But I really believed he was a real person for a long, long time.
Okay.
So I know this one is seven.
Because we have seven in here.
We have seven in here.
Okay.
And then...
How are you still in Sudoku?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Okay.
Bottom right is nine here?
How do you know?
Hold on.
There, we could have a two...
Wait, one...
Five, five, six...
Seven, eight...
This is nine or two.
Nine or two.
So this has to be nine, right?
And then this has to be two.
Wrong.
Bottom right is ten out of ten.
Where did you get your maid dress from?
Probably a fancy...
Boutique!
Thanks, Bill.
Okay.
And then...
So we need one...
Which can't be this one.
It might be this one.
And three...
And eight...
For this box.
This can't be eight.
And it could be three.
One has to go top left.
It does?
It has to?
It's one.
Okay.
And so then eight...
And then three.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine.
Okay.
One box!
There's a one in every row.
Oh!
I see it down here.
Oh, I didn't notice.
I was only looking at the...
At the rows, not the column.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
And then this one.
This can't be two.
So two has to be here.
And...
Three...
Four.
No!
Wrong.
Sorry.
Four...
Three.
Sorry.
I really...
Okay, when you...
When will you guys understand?
Okay.
So...
This...
These...
Neither of these can be two.
This...
So I think...
This one is three.
Ugh.
This one's three.
Four.
And we have five...
Can't be here.
Five.
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Seven...
This is nine.
Okay.
It helps when you have an already solved corner.
Because you can just kind of like...
You can just...
Continue from there.
Let's clear my name.
My mom solved that...
Sudoku book.
Minto math class ones.
You can't make me!
I'll never go back!
Oh...
Okay, we have four.
Maybe six?
Wait, what are we missing here?
Two...
Nine...
What else?
Six!
Two-nine-six!
Two-nine...
Two-six-nine.
Okay, so this can't be nine.
This can't be nine.
So this has to be nine.
Uh...
And...
Six...
Uh...
It could be either...
Right now.
It could be either right now.
Uh...
Okay, we'll come back.
You're doing great for a first-ever Sudoku go-around.
Thank you!
Uh...
Okay.
Then...
What else would be easy to solve?
Hmm...
Maybe we'll go down.
I don't know.
Uh...
Three...
Can't be three...
This... Oh, we have three.
We need one...
So one would be here.
Two...
Three...
Four...
Can't be here.
It has to be one of these two.
Hmm...
Five...
Can't be this one.
The...
I wish I could like put...
I wish I could put like a...
Maybe this.
Maybe it's this.
Final ones or bottom row?
Wait, what do you mean?
Five top left.
Do I have some paper?
No, I don't.
Top left must be five.
Why?
Must be.
Oh, yes, you're right.
Cause here...
And here.
Oh!
Thank you.
Okay.
Mine bottom left.
Wait, what?
Bottom left?
Huh?
What?
Six is possible.
What do you mean six is possible to solve?
Who's six?
Where's six?
What?
You guys are going so fast.
I'm confused.
I can do eight now.
What do you mean?
I can do eight.
Hold on.
What do you mean?
I'm so confused.
Stop it.
Stop.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Like I can put eight here?
Is that what you mean?
Okay.
Uh...
No, two.
Um, hold on.
Uh, we need four.
Four.
Uh...
And six.
So...
Oh.
I'll, uh...
No, sorry.
Four.
And six.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Nine.
Okay.
Can we solve this one yet?
What was it?
It was two and six, right?
I don't know if we can yet actually.
Yeah.
Ugh.
Okay.
Let's go...
Let's go down.
This one is...
This one doesn't have very...
This one has a lot open.
Do six, two, three, and a light punch.
Try a column.
Oh, I guess that works too, right?
Um, let's see.
We need two here.
So it can't be here.
Um...
Four.
Can't...
Four is down here.
We know.
Um...
One.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six would be...
We don't know.
Seven.
Eight.
And then nine.
Okay, nine is...
Not there.
Oh, nine is here.
My mind does not want to perceive the grade ones.
Like the numbers that are inputted in, you know?
Um, okay.
So...
Four.
One extra way to solve Sudoku is solving individual numbers.
Each number will only show up nine times.
If there are eight of a number, you know exactly where the last one is without fail.
Oh...
Every week.
I see you.
Hahaha!
Okay.
Um...
One.
So..
And six.
And...
No.
That's okay.
Yeah, I don't think I can do them yet.
One is the center of the bottom middle row.
This?
Wait.
Bottom... middle.
This?
Wait.
I can't tell when you guys are saying... I can't tell you guys say yeah, and I don't know which one it is.
I can post the solution in your live tag if you want.
No, no, no, no, no.
I cheated for all the other ones, so I'm going to solve this one properly.
The center one.
Okay, okay, okay.
One, two, three.
How did you deduce that?
Wait.
There's also here.
We can solve this.
One, three, four, five, six, seven.
This is eight.
We can solve that one.
Okay.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Nine.
Okay, this is seven.
Eight.
Nine.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Seven, eight, nine.
Okay.
And, um...
Uh, okay.
I have enough to solve row four.
Yeah.
One, uh...
Three...
Ah, ah, ah.
Thank you.
Four, five, six...
Seven.
Okay.
I think you can finish ones now.
I'm going to do...
How I do it.
Rather than going by number.
I don't think I can keep track.
Because I...
I can't...
I...
I don't think I can.
Um, let's try...
So, these ones have just...
Two.
So...
Uh, one...
Uh, two...
Okay, I don't know.
Uh, one, two, three, four...
Five...
Six, seven...
Eight...
Nine.
Okay.
Uh...
Let's see.
Hold on.
Hold.
Hold, please.
Uh...
Second and four right.
I don't know what that means.
Uh...
Oh, wait.
I can do this.
Wait.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
So, this is... I can do this one because there's four.
We're missing four.
And then I think it's two.
Okay.
I can do that one.
We need two here.
So, two would go here.
Which means six is here.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine.
And then one, two, three, four, five, six.
Okay.
Kirby movie?
Starring Tom Holland?
What?
Is that real?
Huh?
And then this is two.
Okay.
We need three.
Three is here.
What's one, two, three, four, five.
Okay.
Two.
Uh, seven.
Eight, nine.
And six.
Mm.
Uh, one.
Eight.
All right, I'm pretty good at this.
Shut up, Nancy Drew.
Let's call that guy.
Was it George?
No.
George is... wait.
Let's... I think we gotta call... Bess?
I don't remember who gave us the Sudoku.
This isn't the time to use my phone.
What do you mean?
This is all the time.
I shouldn't talk on my phone here.
In here?
Okay, let's go outside then, Nancy.
Oh my god.
I forgot.
I think that's my...
Thanks, Nancy.
What do you... what did I receive?
I think maybe she liked the picture I sent of her.
Way to make a style and avatar.
Phone Fashion Software is here to keep your whole contact list looking fashionably fly.
Yeah, we made some avatars last time.
Well, if you like it so much, why don't you use it?
Anyway, okay, let's call Bess.
Hi, Nancy.
What's up?
Did you get the avatar I sent you, Bess?
I love it!
Oh, is that it?
How's... how's Kyoto?
How's Kyoto?
It's the best!
Kyoto!
Yumi's been showing me some of the coolest parts of town.
The fashion here is crazy.
Yumi took me to a store.
Looking like a Conan suspect.
I don't even know how to describe this place.
It was pink.
Really, really pink.
It had the pink version of everything you could imagine.
I'm not surprised.
Neither was I.
But I was a little horrified.
But then she took us to see the Gion District.
Gion!
So cool.
She was a little grumpy that we wanted to see some traditional plays, but I think she had fun anyway.
The Gion District.
Guy on what?
What do you guys think of Yumi?
She's so much fun.
A little pushy sometimes.
But I feel like I've known her for years, and we've just met.
She seems to really dislike the Ria Khan.
Do you think she'd want to see it closed down?
Well, I can't say for sure.
She does really seem to resent that place.
Why are you here?
I only called best.
But I'm not sure she'd go as far as trying to get it shut down.
I don't know.
I should go.
I'll talk to you later.
Bye, Nancy!
Let's try calling George instead.
Bye!
Well, how...
Okay, well, how do I contact the guy...
Hold on, let me see.
Oh, I don't have a task list because I'm too good at the game!
Or so I said!
Uh, let's see.
Oh, I have some clues though.
Something seriously spooky is in one of the Ria Khan's mirrors.
But we learned that that can be faked by...
It's like a fake mirror type something.
But whatever the contraption is breaks it each time you use it.
Yumi seems very concerned about the hauntings at the Ria Khan.
Or is she just trying to scare me herself?
Yumi, the oldest Shimizu daughter.
Ren Taro seems pretty good with machinery.
And Miwako is the youngest daughter.
Yes, yes.
Observations.
Oh my goodness.
Everyone I met here is nice...
Nice enough!
Wow, okay.
George sent it to you, but I don't know if you have to send it to the guy...
Yeah, I don't know what to do with it now.
Maybe we...
Talk to...
Miwako.
Oh, okay.
Don't ask her about the old article.
Wait, I gotta save the game.
SAVE THE GAME!
I won't go through that hell again.
Okay.
You can mail the Sudoku at the front desk.
Let's...
Do you want to manage the Ria Khan?
Right now, I have to.
But it's not that simple.
Why not?
It just isn't.
Okay.
Miwako is a little testy.
She's a little...
She's got a little bit of a...
Attitude.
We need to go back to the convention.
Oh, we can try that.
What...
What time is it?
Let's see.
10 PM.
You think he'll be there?
Maybe we should go to sleep...
Then.
I need to translate that.
No, you don't, Nancy!
We translated it last week!
Nancy Drew...
Which one?
Sudoku?
Get me out of that hill.
Oh, here.
Oh, what?
Oh, I guess we don't need to translate it.
Oh, the envelope's in my room!
Yes!
Thank you!
Oh my goodness.
You're right.
They did say, like, if I need to send something, this would be awfully handy to have.
Okay.
You were so right.
Thank you.
Here.
Grab it.
And Sudoku.
Ah!
To...
To George!
Okay.
Now I think we can...
Leave?
Turn around.
This makes me want to play, like, an FMV-style game.
Like, the movement, you know?
Got me feeling...
Hi!
Like that.
Uh...
Can I leave this here for my friend to pick up?
Yes.
Thanks!
From what I understand, the Ryokan has quite the reputation for being haunted.
Thank you for reminding me about the...
It is true that we have the reputation.
The envelope.
Has that been difficult for business?
It is nothing you need to concern yourself over.
Can you think of anyone who would stand to gain if the Ryokan went out?
Nosy Nancy.
No one I know.
We all depend upon the Ryokan.
Even Yumi and Rentaro.
What about someone else?
On the outside?
No.
There's no one else.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
She says, mind your business.
She's like, there's nobody else.
How does your grandma feel about the Ryokan?
How does your grandmother feel about the Ryokan?
The Ryokan.
It's her whole world.
She loves it more than anything or anyone she's ever met.
What does she think of Yumi not working here?
It's a very sore subject for her.
And honestly, I've heard too much about it already.
Ooh, the tea?
What do you mean?
Every day I'm here, making sure all is well.
It would just be nice to hear her at least mention all of the work I do.
Just once.
I'm sorry, this is nothing you want to hear about.
She feels underappreciated.
Do you think Yumi is ever going to come back here to run the Ryokan?
If she knows what's good for her.
Damn!
Why doesn't Yumi work here at the Ryokan?
The Ryokan.
She's very...
My mother used to call her a free spirit.
But that's a nice way of saying that Yumi is selfish and doesn't want to help.
Damn!
Do you and Yumi get along?
No.
So fast!
She's trauma dumping on me.
Well, I'm the one asking the question.
I'm asking the questions though.
Do you guys get along?
No.
How long have you been fighting?
I'm not sure, but she probably picked a fight with me the day I was born.
Did you and Yumi ever get along?
Of course.
Yeah, I'm trauma picking.
That's a Nancy staple though.
She really...
She was a very good big sister to have after what happened with our mother.
Aww.
But soon enough, she was back to being the selfish, manipulative brat she is today.
What if she doesn't seem very bratty to me?
I'm gonna get on Miwako's bad side.
She does seem...
She does seem a little... demanding.
Not demanding.
Manipulative and bratty.
Oh my god.
Trust me.
I've thought this one through.
Damn.
Okay.
I'll talk to you later.
See ya.
Yeah, bye.
Bye.
Don't get on Miwako's bad side, you guys.
She'll call you...
She's...
Damn.
Okay.
So, we have to wait for George to come and pick up the...
The book.
So...
I don't know if she...
Like if we...
If we...
Need to go to sleep for that, or what?
So let's...
I think sleeping would probably be the...
Probably the best thing?
Probably?
Oh yes.
Wait.
Oh, I can't go to sleep yet?
I can't?
Put out the...
Put out the futon.
I'll do it myself.
Since...
I don't have decent service here.
Hello, please.
Let me go to sleep.
Is there a time limit in this game?
I don't...
No, actually.
Please let me sleep!
Do you have any new numbers?
I don't think so.
I have Yumi.
I can call her.
Hello!
Not in...
My...
Uh...
Let's set an alarm...
For...
Um...
It's...
It's 10 PM!
Maybe if I leave the room and come back in...
The bed will be made.
No?
Oh!
Si!
I'm a genius!
Wait.
Go to sleep.
Nancy, go to sleep.
Nevermind.
Thank you, door!
Go!
Some even have different colors for numbers to make it easier to see.
Not this one.
Thank you!
Okay, nevermind.
I thought...
I remember being able to like, click it.
Being like, okay, I'm right for bed, but I guess you have to set the alarm.
Okay.
Um...
Let's set it for...
3...
AM.
Oh boy, 3 AM!
You think she'll...
She'll pick it up by...
11 AM.
I'll be teaching then.
Okay.
I should set...
I'll be teaching then.
Can't set my alarm...
Okay.
I'll be teaching then.
I'll be busy then.
Better call it a night.
I'll be teaching...
Return of DJ...
Oh my gosh, I forgot my...
My alarm is this...
Explosion!
How so I...
Have these students...
I had to do...
Like, I had to grade their homework before.
I guess...
Not anymore.
Hi kids!
Can you say...
Kuro?
Hi kids!
Can you say...
Neko?
Aka?
Alright.
Let's go see...
Did my friend pick up the thing?
She pick it up?
I should go.
I'll talk to you later.
Okay.
See ya.
Let's call George then?
Can't use my phone here.
Oh, Nancy Drew and your manners.
G-g-g-g-g-g.
Oh, whoops.
Wrong.
Oh.
Were you able to...
A word to calm Suki?
Nice.
Yeah.
It's mate.
Got it.
Thanks.
Need anything else?
Did you learn any more Suki commands?
Oh, yeah.
Get a piece of paper.
I've got a bunch.
Tate, that means stand.
Yeah.
Omowari.
Not sure what that one is.
And we've got buruwa.
That means something.
Oh, and shizukani.
I think that's it.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Ma tai.
Chota ma tai.
Bu...
Oh.
Oh...
Okay.
I'm not getting...
I'm not getting very far with you, Woko.
I wonder if we can use these.
That'll be fine.
What do you mean?
She never seems to answer my questions directly.
She's a can.
That's never a good sign.
Ma tai.
I'd keep an eye on her.
She could just be quiet, or she could be hiding something.
So true.
I'll talk to you later.
Talk to you later.
George is so nihongojojo.
I bet, I bet, the creator was like...
Yeah!
Okay, now we have to wait...
Hi!
Okay, until 1am.
We gotta get into that computer, you guys!
I'll let you go.
Bye!
Time skip simulator.
Let's wake up at 1am.
Can't sleep here.
Okay, Nancy.
She's so proper.
Alright, let's go to our room.
And we'll nap.
I don't think there's anything else I can do!
Probably not.
I imagine.
Okay.
One...
Nancy, why can't you just sleep in the lobby, huh?
A.M.
set.
Let's go.
Okay.
Oh, it's one hour... 1am spooky time.
Hi, Suki.
What's up, cat?
Umawari.
What if I say Shizukani?
Shizukani.
Oh, cute!
Cute!
What's up, cat?
Omawari.
I'm scared of what this one's gonna do.
I think I had every right.
I think I had every right to be afraid of what I was gonna do.
Suki.
Let's try burua.
Suki, burua.
Burua, burua.
Who created this?
Suki, who's a good girl?
What kind of sicko?
Suki, mate.
It sounds like Matara speaking Japanese, I'm not gonna lie.
Suki, who's a good girl?
Wait, wait, so I can get in now?
I'd better get back to the case.
Who's my favorite robotic cat?
Suki, mate.
Mate.
What's up, cat?
I should keep exploring.
Wait, what am I supposed to be...
Oh, here we go.
Oh, oh, cutscene.
Suki, mate.
Good news, Suki was actually here to protect you.
The bad news is that thinking Ren is...
Wait, what?
What?
Oh my god, it's the cat.
How did we die?
What's up, cat?
Suki killed me.
Suki, mate.
Oh!
Okay.
What the hell is this?
What is this?
Oh no.
What am I supposed...
Oh!
Okay, okay.
What the...
What?
What is the...
What is the end goal here?
Oh, you got this.
I'm actually not...
Sure what we gotta do.
Wait.
It was make a pattern.
Like it already was the pattern.
Like this.
It's already the pattern.
What?
Can you split them?
It's not letting me...
You see?
Like if I just select one, it won't let me move it to the other side.
Hmm...
What?
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Oh!
What did I just do?
I caught something.
Oh!
Okay.
I'm doing it.
Somehow.
Uh...
Ah!
Okay.
Can they go...
They can only go down.
Oh!
The...
Okay.
Uh...
Can it go up?
It cannot.
Ah!
Oh!
But this also can only go to the right.
Unless...
Wait.
Oh no!
Okay.
Yeah.
I don't...
I have...
I'm literally brute forcing it.
I have no idea what this is.
This is so str...
Oh, wait!
What?
Nancy-san, what the hell is this?
Oh?
I don't get it at all.
But, uh...
We're doing it?
Somehow?
Wait, what if we...
What if we went down?
Oh, we can't.
Okay.
This one is also...
We can't move this one anymore.
More?
It's literally off the screen.
Okay.
And we can't move this one anymore.
Maybe...
We can move it...
If it's...
Like this?
Oh, wait.
Oh!
I wonder what the hit from the puzzle is.
The tabs don't even do anything.
I think we just have to get it all the way over.
Okay.
What the hell is this?
World's most nonsensical puzzle.
No, maybe if...
Ah!
Alright!
It's open!
What the hell was that?
What?
Uh...
We got a razor blade.
I need to translate this.
It says a pasuado.
Nancy-san.
Come on.
Oh, okay.
And then...
Dear Marianne.
It's finally winter.
You'll be here in a few weeks.
And I might just end up giving you this letter in person.
Sorry!
It snowed for the first time last night.
It's always my favorite night of the year.
Miwako and Rentaro came in the house looking like a couple of snowmen.
We had hot tea by the fire.
And for a full ten minutes, Rentaro was too cold to talk.
That was a...
That was really nice.
The password is password.
Just in Japanese.
It had been a while since I'd spent any time around Miwako.
And for once I caught her in a chatty mood.
She's gotten so quiet lately.
She's been like a shadow wandering around the house.
Oh!
Shadow at the water's edge!
Last night she was back to the funny, goofy girl I remember.
Wait.
I remember...
From not long ago.
Then you won't believe this.
Yumi came in and joined us of her own free will.
And then my mother came in.
And we all played a game.
Now you gotta re-lock it.
No one was forced to join in.
There was no bickering.
Rentaro didn't even have a freakout over the rules midway through.
It was like a gift from the universe.
I knew that in the morning we'd be back to bickering.
The complaining.
The moody silences.
But it didn't matter.
One night like that is worth years of near misses.
Who is writing these?
Because it's not Miwako.
It's not Yumi.
So it's not the two sisters.
And then Meri- Who's Meri- There's so many.
I have no idea.
Anything else we can grab here while Suki is matting?
Okay, hold on.
Let's investigate.
Oh, password?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Hmm.
I need a way to open this envelope without anyone knowing I did.
What about...
This?
The razor blade.
Without no...
Anybody...
Maybe the card?
No?
A way of opening it without anybody knowing...
What is this?
Oh, this is my Pacheco stuff.
A way of opening it.
What if we opened it in the...
In the onsen?
No!
I'll have to wait until the banner changes color.
No, don't, don't!
When will that be?
Tea kettle boils water.
Where...
Do we have a tea kettle?
In our room?
Save?
Yeah, I guess we should save.
I wanna be at Mint's Water Edge.
What does that mean?
Maybe...
Wait...
This?
Right here?
Maybe?
Oh, but it's not water.
Ah!
That fire is hot.
Not surprisingly.
Nancy drew.
Just set it on fire.
I need a dictionary to translate that.
Oh my god.
Nancy, please.
I guess not.
Okay.
Wait, I'm stuck.
Ah...
But we can't...
I imagine we can't keep it until day, right?
Because...
Because she'll notice it's gone.
I imagine.
Is there anything out here?
Rentaro?
Oh, he's asleep.
Wait, oh...
Uh...
Does he have a tea kettle or anything?
No.
Is she building metal gear?
Can Suki open it with her claws?
Yeah.
Oh...
The deer scare...
Moving scared me!
Eww...
Do handheld dictionaries actually work for translating stuff?
I don't think so.
I mean...
Pro...
Like...
Yes?
Right?
They have to.
Who's my favorite robotic cat?
I should keep exploring.
How...
Let's...
Let's set a timer for like 3am.
Oh boy, 3am.
Oh wait, I have to do it in my room.
And then maybe it will be ladies hour.
Everybody knows...
Bewitching hour?
No.
3am is the ladies hour.
Locked.
Oops.
Okay.
Drew Crew.
What is that from?
I see so many people say Drew Crew.
Oh, why am...
Why am I...
Doing that?
3am.
Alright.
Our explosive...
Wake...
Up.
And it's...
No!
Why?
It's men only right now.
Why do the men have...
So many hours?
Just the name of the scene.
That's fun.
Yeah.
What
are we...
Stalk out.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Can you advance the time?
And that's what we just did.
How...
What do we do?
Just wander until...
The...
Ladies hour?
Before?
Or...
Will they even change it?
Before...
Before we...
Get to...
I mean...
I don't even know if...
If what I'm trying to do is correct either.
Need a hint?
Maybe there's another way to open it.
Yeah...
I just don't know what...
But...
Oh gosh.
Scared me, Mom.
Down here is just...
The culture room.
Yeah...
Oh...
I don't think there's anything up...
Here?
I don't remember being able to go into any of these rooms anyway.
So...
Um...
What was the other thing you got from the box?
I don't know.
I can't tell what this is.
Oh, a tile piece!
Is it to that weird puzzle in my room?
In here?
This tile?
Nope.
Oh.
Uh...
Tile piece?
To what?
I once thought I was going through a lot of cookies per week.
Then Nancy showed up and informed me that it was...
Smugglers?
And there were five secret passages in my house!
What?
Skellum?
Huh?
What?
What does this do with the tile piece?
Is it something in the bathroom?
But I can't go into the bathroom!
It's 3.30.
Surely...
It will be ladies hour now.
Oh my god!
Agh!
Wow, what do we do?
I'll...
I'll set an alarm for 4, I guess.
4am!
I'll be teaching then.
What?!
I should set the alarm for later.
Wait, what do you mean you'll be teaching then?
Nancy Drew, what time?!
I'll be busy then.
I should set the alarm for a later time.
Uh oh, I think we're screwed.
Wait, should I go put it back or are we gonna...
Is it gonna game over if she discovers that it's missing?
Uh...
Excuse me?
For lunch I had a big slice of pizza.
Miso soup with soft shell crab.
Two small cups green tea and a lemon sorbet.
What the?
That sounds amazing.
Would you have it?
Yeah.
I saved...
Yeah, I did save.
I'm just...
You know what?
Screw it.
Oh!
Um...
I'm going to sue this...
Uh...
Complex.
Or this...
This ryokan.
Excuse me?
Um...
I almost caught fire.
What the hell was that?
Wait, I feel like we can use this.
But I just...
Don't have a...
I don't have a thing to use it with.
Ah!
Hold on.
Let's go back to Rentaro's place.
He has like nothing in here.
That we could use for...
Like creating steam.
Isn't there a watering can?
Yeah, but...
It's not that...
Oh...
How'd it get so late already?
I should get to bed.
Okay.
Oh.
We're forced.
Uh-oh.
I guess we'll see!
Ooh!
I guess
we'll see!
I'll talk to you later.
Bye!
She doesn't notice.
Yes!
Haunted hot springs.
Good.
No one's out here.
Okay.
I need a dictionary to translate that.
Is it so steamy that we can use...
Maybe...
Maybe not.
Oh, maybe...
Maybe...
Wait!
Oh!
I got the tile piece.
Where is the tile piece?
Oh, here.
What am I supposed to do?
What's the...
Okay.
Is...
So, do I fit stuff in here?
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh...
I see.
Okay.
Alright, let's figure this out.
Like so.
I wish I could rotate them.
Oh, I can only use the things from here.
What does this do?
Click right to rotate!
Thank you, game.
Okay, wait.
Now we have to restart.
Redo, redo, redo, redo.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Let's just do that.
Do that.
And do this.
I was like, there's no way you can do this without rotating it.
It's not possible.
Oh.
I...
Oh, no.
No.
Where do you fit?
Oh, you are awkward.
Wait, how do you fit the square?
It only goes in the center.
Oh, wait, like...
Okay, hold on.
Wait.
Ah, like that.
Like that.
I got it.
Maybe.
I might have messed it up again.
Oh.
Oh, we're so close.
You were right the first time and stopped.
Well, I didn't know I could rotate.
I just wanted to start over, okay?
I'll...
Where would be...
Maybe like that.
Oh, no.
Cause then I need another small.
I need another small.
Hmm.
The square is messing me up.
I don't even remember what I did the first time.
Wait.
Oh, no.
If I do this...
I have it.
Wait.
I can...
I can just flop.
I can just...
Wait.
I can...
I have it.
Wait.
How did I have...
I did it.
Stop.
I've had it.
Oh, my God.
You can't keep avoiding me.
Leave me alone about this.
No.
Who's peeping it on the hot spray?
You talk to me about moving, and every time I bring it up to you, you freak.
Is it not fair?
No.
Oh, shoot.
Walk away.
Just like always.
Well, maybe I won't be here when you get back.
Oh, shoot.
Speaking Japanese.
Please.
But didn't we learn that...
Didn't we learn that the only...
Uh...
Person who's Japanese in this game is Miwako.
So...
Do you guys mind if I go get some more tea, actually?
Yeah.
The voice actors.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't.
Sorry.
I've been trying to drink a lot of...
A lot of...
Wait, so what did that even do, then?
Cuz...
Oh, whoops.
Wrong thing.
Cuz, um...
We learned that they're having issues.
And then not a whole lot of anything else.
Okay, let me go get my tea.
Let me go get my tea.
Okay.
You can look at...
Here, you don't have to look at the spooky mirror.
You can...
You can look right here.
Okay.
You're...
You're keeping guard in case any...
Any freaks come into the hot springs, okay?
You're keeping watch.
Okay.
Give me one second.
Alright.
So.
We just learned that...
And then we...
Don't know...
Wait, I'm lost.
Oh, just kidding.
Do you think she'll want to talk about it?
Hi.
Oh, check on grandma.
Oh, yeah.
We haven't talked to... I'll talk to you later.
See you later.
What time is it?
Seven.
We're immediately gonna go be like, so, Macchio and your boyfriend, you guys are like the cutest couple.
How are you guys?
Is this a tea?
Nanasi-san, today we learn cha-do, the tea ceremony.
She's the worst of the fall.
Nanasi-san.
Okay.
Flens?
Oh, gosh.
I'm not gonna remember all this.
This is called the kensui.
This bamboo ladle is called a hishaku.
You place the teapot cover on the futaoki.
This is the chawan, or tea bowl.
The tea scoop is called the chasaku.
This is the tea container.
It is called the notsume.
Each object has its proper place in the ceremony.
You must place each item where it belongs.
We're learning so much.
Yeah, from, from, from grandma.
Which is the teapot cover on the futaoki.
This is the futaoki.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm not gonna remember.
This is the futaoki.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm not gonna remember.
Futaoki.
This will be good.
Was this Chakin or Chasen?
I don't remember.
Chashaku.
Why are there so many...
This is... Oh, gosh.
I think this is...
What does the hint say?
Does it?
Let us begin.
No!
This is called the puro.
Oh, this is the puro.
Here we have the Chasen.
Oh, this is the puro and this is Chasen.
Here is the Chakin, the tea cloth.
This is called the kensui.
This bamboo ladle is called a kishaku.
You place the teapot covered on the futaoki.
This is the chawan, or tea bowl.
The tea scoop is called the chasaku.
This is the tea container.
I can't remember at all.
Okay, hold on.
Please shut up!
Grandma, please!
You must place each item where it belongs.
It's so hard to focus.
It really is!
Okay.
This was the furo.
And then this was the chashaku, I think.
Oh, god.
I don't remember.
I can't...
I just can't stop.
Chakin is the cloth.
Oh, thank you.
Small spoon is chashaku.
No, this is the chashaku, no?
This is not a spoon.
This is...
What was this one, then?
Whisk is the chasen.
Oh, okay.
I can't remember.
I don't know.
I've never done a tea ceremony.
Then, hishaku!
Kensui.
Guys, something's wrong.
Let us begin.
This is called the puro.
Here we have the chasen, or tea whisk.
Yeah.
Here is the chakin, the tea cloth.
This is called the kensui.
This bamboo ladle is called a hishaku.
Ah!
You place the tea cover on the kataoki.
This is the chawan, or tea bowl.
The tea scoop is called the chasenku.
This is the tea container.
It is called the natsume.
Okay.
These two are switched.
Each object has its proper place in the ceremony.
You must place each item where it belongs.
Okay.
Alright, Grandma.
Thank you.
Well done, Nansisan.
Wonderful, Nancy-san.
Absolutely wonderful.
I would be honored to be invited to take tea with you.
Thanks.
What's happening?
Is this our room or the... where are we?
The ghost!
Shaku looks like a hammer to me.
What do you mean?
I saw something.
It was the wind, the power lines, and shadows.
This is nothing to worry about.
I'm sorry?
Grandma!
She's gaslighting us.
Why do Yumi and Miwako fight so much?
You're an only child, aren't you?
Well, yes, but...
Siblings fight.
Let me give you some advice.
If you ever have children, Nancy-san, and they are not fighting, it generally means they are hiding something that they have just broken.
Gosh, I can't stand talking to her because she talks so slow, and I can't pay attention.
I can't pay attention.
I don't know what to dread.
Why doesn't Yumi want to work here?
She will.
She is just like her mother at that age.
She listens to no one.
Not even herself.
Why can't Miwako just take over the Ryakan?
You do not understand.
That is not how it works.
But she's here now.
It is not what Kasumi wants.
What do you mean, wants?
Nancy-san, I am sorry, but I am very tired.
I should rest.
Wait, wait, I have more questions for you!
Hello, Nancy-san.
Have you been to Yumi's bento stand?
No.
This family.
They're so like...
They're the most direct Japanese people I've ever heard of ever.
They're so direct.
It's great.
You'd love it.
I taught her how to cook for many years.
I should not have to sit on the train to try her bento.
Oh, okay.
I'll let you go.
Goodbye.
Grandma hates public transportation.
Wait, can I use this for...
Let's see, what do we got in here now?
Can we use this for...
The...
No.
Okay, I guess we just can't sit there.
Oh my god, this scared me!
Oh my god!
Hello?
Yumi!
Yumi's jump scaring us.
With her...
Purikuda.
Whatever.
This is not...
Thank you!
Alright.
Maybe...
We can try it now.
Stay back, please.
That's very dangerous.
See, there's no...
Tea...
Kettle on it.
I feel like...
I feel like she'll see, you know?
She'll get...
She'll get mad at us.
Did it say Roppongi?
No way.
Oh, whoops.
This,
cause it's the ro and the...
Maybe po?
Here?
Oh my god.
Roppongi, baby.
Wait, so...
What...
Do...
Let's go talk to Rentaro, maybe, about...
Their relationship.
I know we can talk to Miwako.
Hello?
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna save.
Okay.
Raiden remembered April 30th, but still forgot to wish me a happy birthday!
Oh, Ray!
Happy birthday!
Sorry Raiden forgot it, but thank you!
Thanks for the super time!
Happy, happy birthday!
Yay!
So, you grew up next door?
My dad and I moved in when I was about seven.
Why do you spend all of your time here when you live just next door?
Never got my room decorated right.
Plus, this place has always been more fun.
And Miwako's here.
And I've got my workshop.
Okay.
Are things not going well with Miwako and you?
As usual, no.
What do you mean, as usual?
But this time, a little worse than usual.
She's mad.
Really mad at me.
I need a way to cheer her up.
Can I help?
Actually, yes!
At the Pachinko Parlor, they've got this collar I keep meaning to get for Suki.
A collar?
Why is there a collar?
If you could get that, it would be huge!
Okay.
I'll see what I can do.
Why did I say that the same way as that, see-through?
Thanks for repairing my screen.
That was pretty embarrassing.
Oh, no problem.
Easy fix.
Just took a little steam to loosen the paper, a little new glue.
No one will ever be able to tell.
Just don't do it again.
Or at least wait until the paper cuts heal.
I think thinking about paper cuts is way worse than getting there.
So I think we'll be able to do it with the steam once we get glue.
Why did I bring it up?
Once we get the glue to seal it back up.
What do you think of Yumi?
Yeah, she's corrupting me.
She's pretty much the older sister you want to have.
She's cool.
She's adventurous.
She's a pain.
She's cool.
But no matter what, she's got your back.
Although, man, can she be bossy.
I'm sure she's already put you to work.
Yeah, a little.
She's cute.
Okay.
I'll stop bugging you now.
Bye.
Okay.
Cool.
Actually, we did get some stuff from that.
So...
Let's go to the pachinko parlor, baby!
I guess we don't do the letter just yet.
Pachinko.
Oh...
Okay.
Where was it?
Oh...
Uh...
Oh, wait.
The way he says cool reminds me of carpets for supper.
I know!
Uh...
Kure?
We'll try it.
We are...
Yeah!
You were right!
Good memory.
Okay.
That must be the collar that Rintaro was talking about.
Shut up.
Okay.
What?
There's so many new prizes today.
All right.
We have...
206, baby.
We're gonna go to our...
That must be the collar that Rintaro was talking about.
Sorry.
We're gonna go to our...
Our...
Uh...
Our lucky...
Lucky one.
I don't remember what I did.
I think I just played a lot.
Wait.
We have unlimited money.
On someone's dime.
We don't know who's...
Whose money this is, but...
Yeah!
Pachinko's Dream!
We need to get 2,000.
No, we're not thieves.
We found it.
In the...
We...
It was lost and found.
By me.
Ooh!
Jackpot!
All right.
We're almost to 1,000.
Nice.
We're already almost halfway there.
You guys.
More!
Again, again!
Again, again.
Again.
Oh!
I forgot to grab my winnings.
Okay.
Again, again!
Who
knew that this was going to become so integral?
So important.
For the story.
Aw, yeah.
Come on, lady luck.
Yeah!
What was that?
What did that mean?
Okay.
How much do we got?
I think we're just a hair.
Oh!
Just 40!
Less than 40!
Okay.
Just a little bit more.
Truly just a hair.
Feeding a ghastly gambling addiction.
It's not my money though!
I'm stealing from this person.
This person probably like...
Went to the...
The ryokan.
And was like...
I'm gonna have the best Japanese vacation of my life!
I put...
I attached this...
Card...
This pachinko card to my actual credit card!
So I never have to think about refilling it.
It just automatically refills it!
And then...
And then they got terrified by the ghost and...
And fled the country.
And then Nancy Drew came.
And was curious.
And nosy.
And stole all his money.
Now they...
Oh!
We're not doing so hot with this one, you guys.
Okay, okay.
But we got enough!
Yeah!
We got enough!
Totally for Suki.
What are these other things though?
Like, what is this?
And this?
What are all these?
This looks like a candle.
Nancy Drew commits credit card fraud.
No, we don't...
No, no.
Have I ever eaten a cactus?
I haven't.
It tastes like...
I imagine it tastes like aloe.
Let's go gambling!
And what's this?
Yeah, this looks like a...
Fan?
Probably?
Hmm...
What's the really expensive one?
This...
I don't know!
It's not as expensive as the dang collar we had to buy.
But...
And we...
Uh...
It's Kurume, right?
Oh no, Misawa.
We are in Misawa.
Okay.
Awesome.
Back to the spooky ryokan.
What time is it anyway?
Oh, it's not even 9 p.m.
Perfect.
All right.
Hi.
I got that collar for Suki.
Oh, Nancy-san, you are the best guest we've ever had.
I'm going to go give this to her now.
Please, excuse me.
Okay.
Bye.
Kind of tastes like grapes.
Wait, can we like explore?
What's this?
071709.
Rentaro, rentaro, rentaro!
Rookie mistake, my friend.
Well, I want to see him give it to her.
Did you like it?
Hi.
Is Suki wearing a new collar?
Yes.
Doesn't it look perfect?
Lindalo must have really put some thought into this.
It fits perfectly, and it goes so well with her eyes.
He can be so thoughtful sometimes.
I think it's time for me to do something nice for him.
Oh?
Yeah.
So, how are things between you and Rentaro now?
Couldn't be better.
Oh, wow.
Okay.
I'll let you get back to work.
I wonder what she would have said before we...
I wonder what she would have said before the collar.
How do I get this?
Okay.
Maybe we know the steam.
But I don't have the glue.
Maybe we...
Let's just still try the...
The bath.
Maybe Nancy will be like, Oh, yeah.
I'll figure something out.
Because I'm Nancy Drew, you know.
What is the music for?
I need a dictionary to translate that.
Okay.
Alright.
Steam it!
Steam it, baby!
No?
Okay.
Mint-chan, mint-chan, mint-san, mint-sama.
Not sama, because I'm a maid.
Can you use the bath?
Oh, wait.
Ah, all mysteries should involve hot springs.
Nancy Drew in the bath.
I can't, like, grab it.
That's what's...
Annoying about it.
It's like, I can't, like...
Click on it, you know.
Like, use in...
Use in...
Bath.
You know?
Hmm.
So, it must be something else.
We already did this.
Oh, do you want me to do it again?
No, no.
I already solved your puzzle.
Okay.
I guess we wait until...
3 a.m.
again.
Or 1 a.m.?
I guess?
I like that Nancy is supposed to be here to teach, and she's just casually got involved in this family drama for no reason.
That's so Nancy Drew of her.
That's so Nancy Drew of her, though.
What do we do?
We have this.
I feel like this goes to something behind there, but I don't remember what.
Yeah, let's go to our bed.
Oops.
Because we can't use this.
Please stay away from there.
It is very easy to get burned.
Yeah, see?
I can't grab it.
Good night, world.
I guess?
1.
Oh.
Yeah.
1.
I went the wrong way, but that's okay.
And now it's spooky music time.
Okay.
Let's go back.
Suki Tate.
Oh, no, no, no.
I mean, not Suki Imate.
Oh, she actually does look...
I was going to say she does look cute with the collar on, but I'm scared of her.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Stop.
Stop it.
Suki, you're scaring me.
Okay, not this.
No?
Wait.
Okay, it's not this.
Ah!
I thought it was one of those cards.
No!
What was something that needed a...
Needed a code.
Can we grab the...
You can't...
Or rather...
I don't know if we should have done it earlier.
I don't think there was a way to.
It's now locked, so we can't go in.
Unless...
Yeah.
It's now locked.
Uh...
The lockbox.
What was the lockbox?
Where?
I thought it was a card on her door.
I wish it would let me see what the numbers were again.
Magnetic key.
What?
What were the numbers on it again?
I can't preview it.
It's a room key, but the where?
I guess we'll go try everything.
Locked.
Okay.
Brute force.
I don't know if anybody remembers the...
Locked.
The number it was.
Oh, whoops.
Okay.
Locked.
I need a key to open this door.
Yeah, I have one.
Okay.
Locked.
I did use it, right?
Okay, yep.
Locked.
And there's no...
Oh, I was gonna say, there's no teapot, but there's not.
Dang it.
Let's go try it on the cultural room.
We can see it.
If maybe that'll work.
Ugh.
Dang.
Locked.
I need a key to open this door.
Guys, I don't know.
Locked.
I don't know.
Maybe we'll get it soon.
I need a key to open this door.
The music is so freaky.
Right now.
Wait, it sounds even scarier than before.
I don't think we've heard this song.
I don't know.
It's so scary.
Locked.
Oh, I just realized I don't have to... Guys, I don't know about this.
I tried all of them.
I tried!
Hmm.
Oh.
Try a little more.
Picky.
So true.
I don't think there was anything else in here.
He's got some pliers.
I'm at a loss.
This is what to do.
This is where...
Locked.
Yeah, we did these ones.
Hmm.
Hint for mint, if anybody has a hint.
I think it might be a badge for the tech convention.
No, I already tried the tea ceremony room.
I think that was the thing with color cards and Miyawako's corner.
No, I wasn't.
I already tried that.
I already tried this.
They don't even look the same.
Did we miss anything at Yumi's place?
Do you think she'll let us in her house?
Do I have... I still have her house key!
Oh my god.
It's time for a midnight stroll?
Trains are done running for the night.
Just kidding.
Ow!
I thought there was a thing in the closet for the tea ceremony room.
I don't think so.
You need to go to Yumi's apartment.
There's a book there you need to look at for a phone number.
Ah!
Okay.
We shall wait until...
Let's go to sleep then.
Thank you!
We shall...
Shall do.
Oops.
Okay.
Good night, everybody.
Good night, world.
We'll set our clock for...
7 p...
6 p.m.?
I don't remember what time she gets off.
I'll be teaching then.
7 p.m.?
It's really late.
I should get to bed.
The Rio-Kan.
All right.
Can we...
We can quit the music.
Yumi, Yumi, Yumi, Yumi, Yumi...
Was in...
Kurume...
I think.
Yumi, Yumi, Yumi...
Yumi's house was...
Kurume...
I think.
What was that explosion?
That's our alarm.
Just, you know, normal.
So there's a book in here.
Not this.
Because we discovered this.
Oh, what's this?
Okay.
You got games on your computer?
She's got avatars.
Oh, these are the ones that I've made.
Oh, God.
They're so scary.
Wait.
Oh.
No.
I don't think it's this.
Dang it.
I was going to say, what were the numbers?
The numbers.
But I don't think it's that.
Because...
It won't let us...
It wouldn't be the numbers if it didn't let us investigate it again, you know?
There's a book here?
I...
I don't...
On her bed, I think.
Ah!
Thank you.
I totally did miss this.
Unveiling ghosts.
Paranormal investigations from around the world.
To the Shimizu family.
Your hospitality during this difficult time has been immeasurable.
Thank you for allowing me into your home and your lives.
If you ever find yourself in the state of Georgia, you've got a place to stay.
Sincerely, Savannah...
Her name is Savannah and she's from Georgia.
I guess we know where her parents...
Where she was conceived.
Is this handwriting the same as all the letters we've been seeing?
I don't have any of them on.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, thank you!
Introduction, A Month in the Haunted Steeps.
Riding the Phantom Pass.
The Breathing Mansion in Booker M.A.
The Spirits of the Civil War.
I'm sorry.
She's like...
This book is called Ghosts from Around the World and then it's all America except the Ryokan.
It looks like someone tore out one of the chapters.
Oh...
Ghost 7.
The Ghosts of Centralia, PA.
Wait, we can't...
We can't see the rest.
Okay, but we got her phone number.
Let's call her and the time zone will definitely not be a problem.
Savannah Woodham's office.
Logan speaking.
Can I speak to Savannah Woodham, please?
Are you one of our interviews?
Interviews?
I'm Savannah Woodham's assistant.
Is she interviewing you about the expo?
The expo?
No, I actually want to speak to Savannah about a book she wrote.
Oh, great!
I'm so glad you called.
Really?
Why's that?
It's been like three days since I've gotten to hang up on anyone.
I wonder if I'm still good at it.
Oh my god!
Logan!
Hold on, this is very important.
What a jerk!
Logan speaking.
Did you just hang up on me?
Oh, absolutely!
Between you and me, it was awesome!
In fact...
Oh my god!
I can't believe he's still picking up.
Uh-oh.
You've reached Savannah Woodham's message service.
I'm not in the office at the moment.
Please try again.
He's so rude!
Okay.
Interesting.
I could just open her doors and...
I saw that someone said that you could go through her closet somehow.
Oh!
There.
I need a dictionary to translate that.
Okay.
Nancy...
They're telling her to die!
Oh my gosh!
It's so threatening!
Does she have any glue?
Wait, what's this?
Oh wait, we can put that in our CD player.
These are so hideous.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
Okay.
We can put it in here.
The mixtape.
Oh
my eyes!
What is this?
Oh god, I'm gonna die in seven days!
What was that?
Nancy, you're gonna die in seven days!
He's for real!
Uh...
Okay.
Um...
What was that?
And we are too!
Oh no!
Not me.
I'm already dead.
Sucks to be here though.
Um...
I wish Minto would threaten me.
What?
What could I threaten you with?
That you wouldn't be like...
Don't threaten me with a good time!
How come you never do that to us?
Do you even want us dead in seven days or no?
Did you not watch my Valentine's Day stream?
Huh?
Also, this was an hour ago.
Sam, I'm so sorry.
I just saw your dono.
I'm glad that...
That my older karaoke gave you some...
Needed energy!
I'm sorry!
I'm sorry.
I just saw it.
I'm so sorry.
Let's see.
Let's talk to Yumi.
Maybe...
Uh...
Maybe we can go visit her in...
Oh gosh.
It was...
Oh god.
Ise!
Oh my gosh.
I love Ise.
Um...
Where was she?
Matsue?
Matsue.
I think.
Adult things.
Like taxes or something.
Yeah!
Okay, cool.
Hi!
I watched that DVD at your place.
It was very strange.
You did what?
Shouldn't I have?
Oh no.
I'm sorry, Yumi.
I'm sure it'll be fine.
Just be very cautious.
What do you mean?
You have to be cautious about everything here, Nancy.
Oh my god.
We really are cursed.
We are cursed!
Oh my god!
Can you tell me more about that?
She's some sort of ghost hunter or something.
I don't know much about it, okay?
But she did a chapter on the Ryokan.
Yeah.
Well, just because my grandmother believes in that junk, doesn't mean I do.
Oh?
Wait, I don't think grandma believes in it either.
I love the picture of George.
Oh.
I know!
Isn't that one great?
Oh!
The picture she sent was of George!
We were like, who is this?
Oh!
I really like your apartment.
You do?
Thanks!
It's just a 1K.
That's code around here for tiny and overpriced.
The location is great and it's mine.
I love it.
When did you move out of the Ryokan?
The second I was old enough to sign a lease.
Best decision I've ever made.
No late night room service.
No annoying tourists calling up at 4 in the morning.
I adore that apartment.
Oh.
I wonder if it knows.
I'm going to get at something nice today.
A new doormat or something.
You mean so weird.
Oh my gosh.
I was talking to someone just the other night.
And they were saying how they knew someone that lived in like a 7 DK or something.
Which is like actually insane.
This is a cursed super chat.
You have been cursed by a ghost.
If you don't repost this message to 7 group chats, a ghost mood will haunt you.
This week.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Yeah, it was like...
It was...
Like they were describing it to me and I was like...
I...
I didn't even know they were so that big.
I didn't even know.
You could get an apartment that big in Japan.
Ducky, thanks for the gift.
Uh...
That last picture of you is great.
Yeah.
I love that one.
She loves that one.
This is a blessed super chat.
All curses are removed.
Oh...
Wait, but I want the curse.
Around.
Yippee!
It was like a 7D...
I think...
It's like 7 rooms and a kitchen.
And...
Like LDK, I think is living, dining, kitchen.
Dorgo!
Thank you so much for the 5KT.
Thank you!
No.
7DK.
Not 7...
Not 7 0 K.
Like 7...
Like it's like 7 rooms.
7 rooms and then...
Dining and kitchen.
Is...
It wasn't my friend.
My friend was describing someone that they know.
Yeah.
7 Donkey Kongs.
Exactly.
I'll let you get back to work.
Okay.
See ya.
I'm not ready to do more bento.
I don't think my...
I don't think I'm mentally prepared for it.
Okay.
Well then.
We got that number.
How do we call her?
Let's try calling...
Oh my gosh.
I always click camera instead.
Let's try calling...
Maybe George can get...
George is pretty good at this stuff, no?
Uh...
I found a strange book about ghosts in Yumi's apartment with a note from the author.
What do you mean?
It had a dedication from the author, Savannah Woodham, to the Shimizu family.
But the really weird thing is, there's a chapter missing.
What was in the missing chapter?
Nope, strike that.
That is a dumb question.
Yeah.
That's pretty strange.
Maybe you can find another copy of the book somewhere.
There's a business card with the author's number inside.
But more importantly, the table of contents says the missing chapter was about the Reacon.
Weird.
Did you call?
Yeah.
I called Savannah, but she's got a really protective assistant.
She's in Kyoto?
Yeah.
Apparently she's in Kyoto now.
How do you know that?
Covering the expo for some tech magazine.
Wait, how do you know that?
So she's pretty busy.
If I could get past her assistant, I could finally figure out what this whole book is about.
Wait, so this guy is at the expo?
Pretty sure.
Then we've got this one.
See?
We do?
Yup.
We're going to find them, and you're going to flirt up a distraction.
I am?
Yes, you are.
I think the assistant only mentioned the expo.
But he did not say kill them.
What?
Okay.
And then also this one.
I think there's something pretty strange about Rintaro.
Yeah.
The way Yumi tells it, he's about as weird as they come.
Do you think he could be behind what's going on?
Hard to say for sure.
Well, he may be strange, but sometimes strange just means... strange.
I was hoping to talk for longer so I could snack.
I'll talk to you later.
Bye!
Okay.
Cool.
They're going to flirt with that guy.
Probably tell me about it tomorrow.
Where do we go home?
Misawa.
Okay.
Yeah.
I think that's all we...
Oh wait, what is this?
This looks important.
I better hang on to it.
Oh.
No way.
I just saw that just now.
Puzzle boxes have been bewildering buyers since the late Edo period over a hundred years ago.
These beautifully crafted boxes are both a joy to look at and a challenge to solve.
Traditionally requiring four to sixty-six moves before the lid can be removed.
To open, pieces of the box are slid in a specific sequence.
Unlocking hidden catches after correct moves.
Once the sequence is complete, the lid will open, revealing the hidden compartment within.
So we totally...
I'm totally a genius.
I did not need that at all.
Yeah, it also didn't really even explain it.
What time is it?
Can we...
You think the grandma's still around?
Wait, she might be.
We might be able to go...
Oh my goodness.
If it's from Yumi...
I got...
Ew.
Wait, it's not from anybody.
Uh...
Okay.
Nice, we can talk to grandma.
Hello, Nancy-san.
I need to know.
Do you believe the Ria Khan is haunted?
Yes, Nancy-san.
This isn't a trick someone is doing.
Wait, then why did she gaslight us earlier?
Kasumi.
She's still here.
I can feel it.
She's trapped.
And she's scared.
And...
She's angry.
Angry.
Do you really believe that?
When I was a girl, the most beautiful sparrow from the garden flew into my room.
I had been trying to lure it in with seeds I'd stolen from the gardens for weeks.
At first, I was so excited to have her in my room.
But not for long.
She couldn't find her way back out.
She became very scared.
Threw herself into the walls in a panic.
Oh my god.
I was so worried she would die.
She was so smart and so frightened.
I opened the windows wide and snuck out of the room to let her calm down.
An hour passed.
You should free her!
Then two...
Three...
I'd open the door and still she'd be there.
Crashing into the glass, trying so desperately to get me.
Did she get out?
Cosme is still here.
I must help her.
Okay, Grandma.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh, sorry.
Yes, Grandma?
I'm sorry.
I cannot talk right now.
She's got a nap.
Okay.
No, I thought the...
I think the game, like...
I think the game had a bit of a...
Yeah, so there's nothing in here.
I don't know...
Oh!
We can open this now!
I can't take this if Dekai is here.
Ah, but she's asleep!
Oh my gosh, wait.
I can't take this if Dekai is here.
So now we can get that.
But how do we get it?
How do we get it?
Hmm...
I don't think the door...
Cos we try and the door doesn't open it.
Hmm...
Huh, huh, huh, huh.
Knock her out.
Oh, oh.
Hi!
I don't...
Hold on.
I'll save before I ask you any of these questions.
Okay, see ya!
Hi!
Why does Dekai think your mother's ghost...
Stop.
I don't indulge her.
And don't you do it either.
So, you don't believe it?
That's my mother you're talking about, Nancy.
You forget that.
Yeah, that's actually so...
So...
I'll stop bugging you now.
That's so...
Okay, see ya!
Nancy, come on!
Oh.
Mushy-mushy.
Nancy, operation distract Logan is a go.
Call Savannah.
Gotta go.
Oh, oh.
Thank you.
Call.
Rude Nancy.
Hello.
Hi.
Is this Savannah Woodham?
Let me guess.
You're that Nancy girl who's been driving my...
Oh, she's Southern!
Well, I wouldn't exactly say that.
She's real Southern.
I would.
She's a Georgia girl.
Now tell me what's so important that y'all ruin my perfectly good assistant.
Since y'all been calling around, talking to him's been like talking to a rock.
A rock that I pay too much money.
I'm staying at the Ryukon Hiei.
Something really strange is going on here.
Don't tell me a lie now.
This a joke?
No, I promise.
It's the truth.
I saw your book.
I thought maybe you could help.
Honey, whoever you are, my best advice to you is to pack your bags and head back to wherever it is y'all come from.
I'm not leaving until I figure out what's really going on here.
Don't tell me a lie now.
Is there gonna be anything I can say that'll change your mind now?
No.
I'm going to get to the bottom of this with or without you.
But I could really use your help.
Yeah.
I've been a lot of places that say they haunt it.
But none fit the ticket like that spooky old Ryukon Hiei.
Ryukon Hiei.
I never got to finish up a chapter on the Ryukon like I was supposed to.
Between us girls, I'm glad that.
The Ryukon.
I'm glad that.
You getting much out of the family?
Nothing too useful.
Uh huh.
Tell you what.
You end up following through with that bad idea y'all's to stay at the Ryukon?
And I'll see what help I can provide.
But Nancy?
What's that?
Y'all be careful there now.
You understand me?
I will.
Oh my gosh.
We could get the full lore dump here.
Holy cow.
Okay.
We're unlocking so many different ways to say the Ryukon.
Let's...
I think I ran across a trick mirror here.
Did it break?
Yeah.
How did you know?
That's how you know it's a trick.
Y'all know what the main difference between truth and illusion is in my line of work?
What's that?
Time.
An illusion can only last so long before it gives up its secrets.
Now, I don't know exactly how that mill was fixed.
But the fact that it broke means that whoever rigged it, knew it if you examined it enough, you'd figure it out.
So, it was broken, so I couldn't figure out how it was faked.
No.
Exactly.
That is, if it was a trick.
Nancy, I can tell you how things might be faked, but I can't tell you if they were faked.
So true.
Someone's got to stand there and know how the room feels when these things happen.
No, but didn't we read the thing that said that if you did the mirror trick, it would shatter it?
Because that was like part of the illusion?
Or whatever?
Hmm.
Oh gosh.
What is a yurei?
It's a vengeful spirit that never knew justice here on the earth.
Oh!
They're said to be the spirits of those who've been wronged.
And they're caught up in the worst moment you can imagine.
They're very angry and very, very dangerous.
If that's what you're dealing with there, you best be very careful.
Hahaha.
Hahahaha.
What's the story with your assistant, Logan?
He's like my own little Georgia Bulldog.
He can be a little aggressive sometimes.
A little dopey at others, but always loyal.
He's one of the good ones when you get right down to it.
How long has he been working for you?
I don't really care about Logan.
Not long now.
He started right after I switched my focus to tech reporting.
Why did you change careers?
It's a long story, but...
Chasing's not the safest career there is.
Ain't nothing shocking in that.
Oh, she got spooked out of it doing it.
Ooh.
She's a bulldog.
A bulldog.
Um...
Oh!
Can you translate me in...
Wait, she can speak Japanese?
Can you help me translate an article I found?
No one else is willing to.
Sure.
Leave it at the cannon and I'll have Logan swing by to pick it up.
Uh-oh.
Wait, but they're gonna know.
Wait, we'll put it in the envelope.
We'll put it in the envelope.
I saw a really creepy shadowy figure on my balcony.
Do you think that could be faked?
Of course.
Ain't nothing harder than that.
Yeah?
It's as easy as shadow puppets.
I'm turning into Nancy Drew!
In my experience, people like scaring people with shadows a lot more than ghosts do.
Oh my god.
The way I see it, if it's something a person could plausibly do, then there's a person behind it.
If it's something a person can't do that's scaring you, well, y'all don't need me to finish that sentence.
No!
If it's something a person can't do that's scaring you.
Oh, freaky.
Okay, just a few more.
Can you tell me about the certificate you gave the Shimizu family?
Oh yeah, that.
Now, before you go thinking I'm some sort of charlatan, I don't normally do things like that.
In fact, I had those made up to give to kids who were feeling too scared to go to sleep at night.
Why did you leave one here?
I felt like I should leave them something.
I don't usually leave a place without knowing what's really going on there.
Honestly, I felt so bad about the whole situation.
That doesn't seem very reassuring.
So you just were like, here's a...
Here's a piece of paper!
What?
Why would you do...
What is the logic here?
Miss Savannah.
What happened that made you give up ghost hunting?
It wasn't just one thing.
It was a lot of things, really.
My daddy used to tell me, sugar...
Ug woman, am I right now?
Y 'all be careful what you go looking for in that big old world.
Chances are, you gonna find it.
What did you end up finding?
It ain't what I found, honey.
It's what found me.
What do you mean?
Exactly what I said, and that's the last you're getting out of me on the topic.
You got anything else you need?
God, Nancy is so nosy!
Do you know where I can get a copy of your book?
I'm guessing you're looking for the ghost hunting of the world, but I can't help you there.
I'm out of copies myself.
To be honest, Nancy, I don't mind helping you.
But this whole ghost thing is a phase I'd sooner put behind me.
Why is that?
Oh my god, we...
Now, don't y'all worry about that now.
She clearly does not want to talk about it.
There must be some reason.
Oh my god.
I understand you were pretty well known.
Put it this way, Nancy.
There are some jobs where being well known makes for a dangerous life.
Sometimes it's, uh, smart to move on.
Aw.
That's so scary.
Oh my god.
Savannah has the mafia going after her.
What is happening?
I'll talk to you later.
Bye bye, Nancy.
Yeah, Nancy does not know bound.
Oh my god.
Oh!
This must be...
This must be, uh, George.
And this must be Bess.
Since we had...
This is George.
I guess.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's go, um, seal up this article.
Oh!
Ew!
It looks like whoever left those footprints walked right through the wall.
Nancy, this slides open.
Ew!
Are they in my closet?
No.
Ew!
She's so...
Okay.
And then the article.
To Logan.
Nice.
Okay.
Now we can't investigate it yet, so...
Oh, that's gross!
Who's in my room?
They got big feet.
You know what they say about ghosts with big feet.
Oh, sorry mom.
Hi.
Uh...
Can I leave this here to be picked up?
Yes.
Thanks.
Is the symbol on the door the same as the card key?
Well...
It seems like you and Rentaro were pretty close.
Yes.
We grew up together.
I have a few memories before Rentaro, but not many.
How long have you two been dating?
I don't even know.
A long time.
Oh.
You sound a little frustrated.
Sometimes it's hard not to be with Rentaro.
What do you mean by that?
What do you mean?
Never mind.
I shouldn't be bothering you with this.
Oh, it's not a...
It's not a bother.
Nancy Drew!
It's just that...
When he gets it in his mind that he wants something, there's just no stopping him.
He's been pressuring me to leave here.
Why is that?
He keeps saying it'll be good for me, but really, he's just being selfish.
I think.
I really don't know.
I think he's trying to scare her out of here.
He can be so sweet sometimes, and other times it's like there's only him in the world.
I should go.
I'll talk to you later.
See you later.
Okay.
Um, let's see.
Oh, I think you're right.
I think it is the same card.
Wait, are we not gonna mention the feet in...
In our...
In our room?
Logan here.
Yes?
Alright.
Savannah wants me to translate that article for you.
Oh, Logan.
I don't know what it is you said to her, but whatever you did to get her to talk about that paranormal garbage, you need to knock it off.
I can't promise that.
You really don't get it, do you?
This ghost stuff isn't a joke, especially not to her.
Since I'm the one stuck picking up the pieces after she gets too wrapped up in one of her cases, I'm telling you, leave it alone for her's sake and yours.
Okay.
What happened to Savannah?
Why doesn't she work with paranormal cases anymore?
It's not something she likes to talk about.
I gathered that, but can you tell me...
But you, yeah, you can talk about it.
When we're traveling, I spend weeks with her just touring on buses, long plane flights, we talk a lot.
I know everything about her childhood.
Her best friend's dog's name from when she was five.
Okay, this is not about the ghost.
She's very chatty.
Then, what has she told you about?
Nothing.
Not a single word.
I've asked, and when I do, she just goes quiet and excuses herself.
She's never told me to stop bugging her about it, but I can tell that she wants to.
That's why I don't want you bothering her about it either.
Whatever happened when she was writing the second ghost book, it really got to her.
That's spooky.
Second ghost book?
Wasn't supposed to mention that.
Whoop!
It's a secret, and it's not done, so don't think you're going to get your hands on it.
I don't even know if she still has the manuscript.
She had me tell her publisher she burned it, but I don't know if that's the truth.
Oh!
Interesting.
Interesting, interesting, interesting.
Ha ha ha!
Um, let's see what the article says.
Have you finished translating the article yet?
Just about.
I'll have it sent to you as soon as I finish.
Okay, thank ya!
Wow.
I really need a copy of Savannah's book.
Can you help me?
Sure!
Bookstores are a great start.
Or the internet is helpful.
But I'm really more of a brick and mortar person, honestly.
Oh, you need a book?
Go to the bookstore!
The book's on tape route.
TV's Ralston Pauper's does an excellent job with the text.
Really makes it come alive.
No, I meant, could you send me a copy?
Oh!
Nope.
But thank you for asking.
Oh, but you
mean thank you for asking!
How long have you been working for Savannah?
Started a few years back as a fill-in gig during spring break.
Eventually she needed a long-term assistant, and the job was just too weird to turn down.
That's fair.
Oh, okay.
I'll stop bugging you now.
Talk to you later.
Thanks!
Okay, what were we- Oh, we were going up to the room.
Guys, things are getting real freaky!
Things are getting real freaky!
They took the two off our door!
Trying to get us out of here.
Holy cow!
It did work!
Oh my gosh!
Whoever saw that?
You're a genius!
We're just in someone else's room though.
Okay.
I'm trespassing.
I'm breaking and entering, but...
There's nothing in here though.
Well, that was 22.
Okay.
Spooky!
So spooky.
Wait, is this the last person that's been staying here?
When we first walked in the door, my wife told me she had a bad feeling about this place.
But no, I told her she was being unreasonable.
But whatever it is that's going on down here, we are not putting up with it anymore.
What's this accent?
The thing you left in our room!
No one should ever see something like that.
Aussie?
I want my money back.
There was nothing there.
And I want to see this place closed down!
Oh, yeah!
You'd never get away with something like this in Sydney!
Sir, please, we are not haunted.
Now, please yourself!
Oh!
Don't mind if I do.
Mew!
Oh, this is so sad.
Oh, Mew Echo!
Oh!
It's just us now, isn't it?
Crikey!
Oh, we're the only ones staying here now!
That was the last customer, wasn't it?
Yes, Nancy.
It's just you.
So, make yourself comfortable.
We are all here for you until something happens to scare you off, too.
I don't scare easily.
Except that cat!
I've heard that before.
Look, I'm sorry I shouldn't be upsetting you with all of this.
Please.
You're my only guest left.
Let me at least make sure you have a good trip.
Maybe you recommend us to your friends.
That guy definitely did not swear enough to be an angry Australian.
I still want to help.
Help?
You want to help?
Look around you.
This place is beyond help.
It was spooky and lonely before...
Everything that happened, happened.
And now...
Why do you think Yumi got out of this place as soon as she could?
People come because they heard it's haunted.
They come here to be scared and even they can't take it.
I'm sorry, Nancy.
There's nothing you can do here.
Help yourself and find somewhere safer to stay.
Okay.
Um...
We still need to...
Try and...
What's...
Oh my gosh.
Who's sending me messages?
Oh.
Last evening, officers responded to an emergency call from 15-year-old Shimizu Yumi after she found her mother, Shimizu Kasumi, 42, who runs the Ryokan Hiei, lying unconscious in the indoor Ryokan bath.
After arriving...
Ew!
We've been bathing in a place where the bomb died?!
No way!
Oh my god!
After arriving, emergency crews were unable to revive the apparent drowning victim.
Police are currently treating the case as a crime, but have yet to press charges.
If this is an accident, that's it.
The article ends there.
Logan.
Okay.
Hmm.
Let's...
So are we now in a murder mystery?
Hello, Nancy-san.
Oh boy.
Okay.
Uh...
I have to go to the bathroom real quick, but...
Can you tell me a little about Kasumi?
Let's listen to this.
She would have been quite fond of you.
What?
Quite fonded?
She always loved people who sink for themselves.
And she loved stubbornness.
Hey!
She sinks for herself.
That is not always a bad quality...
I'm sinking!
I'm drowning here!
Oh, too soon?
Oh god.
Kasumi herself is very stubborn.
Was very stubborn.
But it made her the most beloved of the children in her school.
How insensitive!
That's how she died!
When she was young, she could never stand to see injustice done to others.
It made me very proud of her.
But that also has its bad side.
How so?
Grandma!
I'm sorry.
I shouldn't bore you.
You must not worry about these things, Nancy-san.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, wow.
There's a lot.
Okay, go on.
What happened the night Kasumi died?
It is not always good to be so curious, Nancy-san.
I thought she was gonna kick us out.
Okay.
Yeah.
We don't...
Nancy, what an insensitive question to ask.
Why would you...
Do you remember when Savannah Woodham visited?
I don't recognize the name.
She's the one who wrote about the Ryokan.
I said...
I do not know who she is.
So then...
Oh.
Someone else, then.
Talk to her?
What do you think about Rantaro and Miwako dating?
Those two are so different.
When they were children, you couldn't keep them in the same room.
Aloe's so much fighting.
That has not changed.
Except now.
They say they're in love.
Oh.
I saw watery footprints in my room.
It was very strange.
Yeah, yeah.
You must be mistaken.
No, I'm positive.
Yeah, it happened.
No.
It is not wise to joke about these things.
Does grandma...
I'm not.
I do not want to talk about it.
Does grandma think this place is haunted or not?
I'll talk to you later.
Goodbye.
Does she think this place is haunted or not?
I can't take this if Takai is here.
Okay.
We're gonna have to somehow...
Come back.
Maybe we can...
Let's see.
Oh, we might be able to, like...
I should wait until Takai is gone to open this.
We might be able to get into one of the rooms and then, like, use the doors to...
You know?
To, like, get into one of...
Whoops.
Whoops, sorry, my bad.
Into, like, this...
One of these and then just go down, down, down.
You know?
So let's try that also upstairs.
It's our...
Freaky door.
That wasn't red before.
What?!
Okay, ghost.
You're doing too much.
Squidward!
Thank you so much for the...
This is...
This is too...
This is too much.
You're...
You're milking it.
Way too hard.
So funny.
I'll turn the...
I'll turn her name and her room red!
I don't think I'd be able to sleep in this place, though.
What time is it?
Okay, nine.
I don't think I'd be able to sleep in this place, though, if all my doors are open.
Okay.
Nothing here.
There.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Here.
There's the futon...
God, the music scared me!
Eww!
Okay.
Nothing else here.
I wouldn't be able to sleep with that robo-cat.
So true!
Why is this game so scary?
Okay, this is our room.
We're just breaking into everybody's room.
We already checked this one.
Let's check this one out.
Okay.
Nothing.
I'm scared.
I'm scared there's gonna be a jump scare.
Oh.
Wait, I think that's the end of the road.
Hmm.
Okay.
Not much of anything, then.
Mint didn't pee.
Yeah, I'm gonna go do that.
Alright.
Now.
Yeah, I'm gonna do that before a jump scare happens.
You know?
And I'm like...
And then...
Uh oh.
Okay, it's boy's hour.
Okay.
I'll be right back.
Anything spooky happen?
Let's save.
Anything spooky happen while I was gone?
Okaeri.
Tadahima.
Vinto isn't here so I can finally say my truth?
Oh.
Okay.
Let's try...
Oh wait.
We can't call anybody in here.
Let's call somebody here.
Maybe...
Besh?
Thank you for all the super chats, you guys!
Thank you!
There were watery footprints in my room that led straight into a wall.
Why are you still there?
You've lost your mind.
You know how in the scary movies you always wanna yell, Don't go in that door!
But they never can hear you?
Yeah?
Well, you can hear me.
So, don't go in that door!
I already did though.
Call this mystery a wash and come stay at our hotel, which has a nice ghost-free view, and a ghost-free pool, and tiny, overpriced, ghost-free packets of peanuts.
That's a nice offer, but I think I'm getting close to figuring out what's going on here.
Since you won't listen to Reason, you're gonna have to listen to George on this one.
Ghost-free!
Thanks a lot, Bess!
Unfortunately, I don't have a clue about what to do with this one.
Ghost-free!
But Nancy, whatever's going on out there, be careful.
I will, promise.
Is that like one of those child-free resorts, except it's ghost-free?
No.
Do I get to stay for free?
Maybe.
I had another strange run-in with a ghost here.
What happened this time?
Yeah, free for ghosts!
I was in the hallway, and one by one the door started to slam.
And I heard the sound of water dripping.
Creepy.
Just thinking about that, I'm not going to be able to sleep tonight.
Not sure how you do it.
Creepy.
It is a little creepy, I'll admit that.
I just need to figure out how someone could do it.
Good call.
It could be pretty easily automated, I think.
What are we waiting on?
What other stuff is there?
I'll talk to you later.
Bye!
I'm trying to think.
Maybe you, me?
Hello!
Not in!
Bye-bye!
Call Savannah.
I don't know.
I don't know if there was anything else we could get out of her.
Logan speaking.
Is this Nancy?
Yeah.
Great!
I'm so glad you called.
Why?
So you can hang up on me again?
Oh, that.
Don't take that personally.
I'm an assistant.
My job mostly consists of hanging up on people.
Oh, my God!
I met your friend, Bess.
And this is probably awkward, but I know we haven't gotten off to the best start.
But I'm really not a bad guy, and she's really cute.
And maybe you could help a dude out?
Alright.
What?
Well, she said she's going to be hanging around the expo, and maybe you could, like, tell me about what she likes, or maybe give me some idea of what I might say until the awkward pauses.
Hang up on him!
But for the last while I've been with Savannah, most of my conversations have been about ten seconds long.
And they usually end up with me hanging up on someone.
Oh, my God!
And I don't think that's going to cut it.
Oh, I see.
Slept in a haunted hotel, it was just bed bugs.
Do you think you could help?
Well, I was talking to her, and she really wants a copy of Savannah's book.
Oh, I see what you did there.
Okay.
As a gesture of goodwill, I'll do it.
Hey!
I'm sorry I hung up on you.
Yeah, you should be.
That's okay.
And Nancy, I might have to do it again.
But should that happen, it's just business.
Bye, Logan.
Suica!
Welcome to the bamboo ship!
Thank you!
Oh,
Logan.
Okay.
I remember, we were going to see if maybe one of these were open.
locked.
Locked.
I need a key to open this door.
We don't have any keys to open these.
You know?
So...
And we only...
Oh.
Wait.
We only have until 10.30.
And it's...
Oh!
We have three minutes.
How do we get inside?
We still...
Because I need the tea kettle for this.
And we still haven't been able to...
So there was also...
This...
The...
Like the...
Card puzzle that I haven't been able to do.
Because I don't have the other card.
And I can't get the password.
Hello?
Oh my god!
Can we just say that?
I know what happened to your mother.
I told you to...
It was an accident.
I think you...
All of you...
Blame yourselves.
It wasn't an accident.
But since you won't let it drop.
You wanna know why we all blame ourselves, Nancy?
Why?
Because...
We were all here.
We were all here that night.
And not one of us helped her.
We all just let her die...
Alone.
But you didn't know.
Leave me alone, Nancy.
Oh, Nancy.
This is the worst way of trying to comfort anybody ever.
Hello?
Hello!
Um...
Okay, uh...
Miwako seems a little frustrated lately.
Why wouldn't she be?
The way guests have been filing out.
But maybe she'll finally come to her senses and move to the city with me.
Oh, so he definitely wants to get out of here.
And like, do...
I think he's trying to scare her out.
Or like...
Not scare her...
But like, you know...
He's just trying to make it so that the place isn't profitable.
So that...
She'll leave.
I think it's...
Dentaro!
Not...
Sure-ace.
Is that how you say it?
Thank you!
Welcome to membership!
It's like not pressuring her because he's not the one to be the bad guy, you know?
It's the ghost that's the bad guy.
If he were to be like, Miwako, I wanna leave!
I wanna leave!
And she's like, no, no, no!
I have to run the ryokan!
Then...
He's the bad guy.
But if it's the ghost that's causing the ryokan to close down, then it's not his fault.
So how long have you and Miwako been dating?
Officially, four years and seven months.
Non-officially, longer.
What do you mean by that?
What do you mean non-officially?
And before that, a long time of me waiting for her to stop being so stubborn and agree to go out on a date with me.
But truthfully... this is Rentaro's thoughts.
Truthfully, we've always been dating.
Oh my god!
Rentaro, you're delusional!
Well, maybe not.
They're actually dating, but holy cow!
What does Takai think of your relationship with Miwako?
At this point, I think she considers me part of the family.
Or at least she lectures me like I'm one of the family.
Oh boy!
I'm choosing to interpret that in a positive light.
She's always been my... I'm... I'm Rentaro and she's my Miwako.
Oh, the music.
I thought something was in my room.
I saw some guests just leave.
I saw some more guests just leave.
They seemed pretty spooked.
Yeah.
Those poor people.
Oh, he sounds so insincere!
Who knows?
They were too upset to make any sense.
Those poor people.
I took care of their room after they left.
I admit, it was a little spooky.
Everything was torn up.
Like someone had taken the whole ryokan and given it a shake.
And the shoji had turned this dark ash cutter.
Something weird happened in there.
Wait, can we find their room?
Can we find it?
This is broke, eh.
Is that the same answer when people ask how long you and Snake have been dating?
Hey.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Miwako seems a little annoyed that you want her to leave the ryokan.
Ha.
Tell me about it.
Are you going to keep it up?
Yeah, it's not just a selfish thing.
It's for her own good, too.
It's not just a selfish thing.
At least he admits it.
When did the ryokan get a reputation for being haunted?
A few summers back.
We were fully packed that night.
It was festival time.
There was this terrible scream coming from the baths.
Next thing I know, the paramedics were there.
Oh my god.
This woman had seen something.
She went into shock.
I didn't welcome the membership.
Thank you.
What had she seen?
She never said.
A lot of people asked.
Trust me.
Wait, do you think that's...
What's her name?
I thought she saw.
That's gotta be Savannah.
Everyone else wanted to see it, too.
People started coming and pretending they could send spirits or whatever.
Maybe?
Right?
She saw Rentaro looking through the little people.
What?
Nothing.
Never mind.
It's nothing.
Wait, people started coming and pretending they could see...
could send spirits.
Oh, maybe not.
A few of them.
Nothing.
Never mind.
Oh, maybe not.
Maybe not.
People!
How are things going between you and Miwako right now?
You know how in the romantic movies the couple is only really happy together for like a minute at the very end?
What?
I guess so.
That's sort of how our relationship is.
Except the movie restarts every week.
Honestly, it gets a little tiring sometimes.
I don't think you guys are good for each other.
I'll stop bugging you now.
Catch you around.
I don't think you guys are...
I think this...
This relationship is...
Is...
Is pretty over.
I just...
You know, you don't have to date your childhood friend.
Like...
Okay, what time is it now?
10.39 PM.
Ah...
I'm just not sure what to do.
Locked.
And like, this won't work, right?
No.
Locked.
I need a key to open this door.
So it's...
We gotta get a key for 16, I think.
Unless...
Nah.
Ffff...
Mmmmmmmm...
Hmm...
On off again.
90% off.
Right?
So we're waiting on the book...
From...
From Savannah...
From Logan.
We need to get the thing for the password.
What is this?
Dossier?
Oh, yeah.
Call him again?
Yes.
Let me... I'm gonna go up to my room real quick and make sure nothing's changed in there.
Are all the doors gonna be open now?
Oh!
Someone.
Made the bed for me, though.
Anything here?
What's your name?
Oh, I already graded these, didn't I?
Yeah.
Oh, they're all the same.
I bet.
Oh, no!
Okay.
Family.
Sakura.
Well, see, we need to grade these.
I has three sisters.
Uh-uh.
Do you have a sister?
I share my rooms.
Rooms?
I has none pets.
She speaks in cat... I has burger... Burger... Cheeseburger speak.
Do you have a sister?
I has none pets.
I feel like I share my rooms is technically... It should be I share my room, but... Maybe she has multiple rooms.
I don't know.
My twin is sister.
This is scary.
I don't like it.
Do we have brothers?
What exactly is the line between intrusive nuisance and legitimate detective... Right?
We leave... Okay, that's just real sad.
I have gerbil.
Do we have brothers?
I don't know.
I mean, I'm asking you.
Oh!
That's your homework.
I am an only child.
Does he have a sister?
We live in Kyoto.
I have a cat... Oh my gosh.
Oh, Fumiko is like... A genius.
Oh my gosh.
I am an only child.
Does he have a sister?
We live in Kyoto.
I have a cat.
Oh my gosh.
Genius, Fumiko.
I'm one brother.
We're many sisters.
We live in my home.
My bird is mine.
Sad.
Technically correct.
My bird is mine.
Yippee!
These are more how I feel about them, more than if they're correct or not.
I have none, brother.
How many brothers have you?
We live in an apartment.
Oh, that's correct.
We have many fish.
Good.
I have none, brother.
Okay.
That was family.
Now at home.
My mom is in the kitchen.
I likes to play by well.
Don't do that.
Actually, Sakura, don't do that.
She's gonna get isekai-ed.
Do you have a pikikli?
Oh, what was it?
An A apartment?
Oh, no.
Did I miss it?
I misread it.
It's fine.
Do you have a pikikli?
I has a red pikikli.
My dad is in the study.
I leak puzzles.
Do you have a...
Why are you afraid of the letter E?
All right, genius, Fumiko.
My mother is in the kitchen.
I like to read.
Do you have a bicycle?
I have a blue bicycle.
Star, star, star, star, star-studded student.
My bird is in my room.
I play baseball.
Have you a bike?
Have at you.
Yes, I have a bike.
I play baseball.
That's right.
My bird is in my room.
My brother is in the den.
I play video games.
Do you has a bike?
No.
Chat, if you have a red pikikli, please consult your doctor.
My brother is in the den.
That's good.
I play video games.
Do you has a bike?
Sad.
No cat speak here, please.
Okay.
So we graded those.
Our name is now in red.
Because the ghost is like, gotta make it real ominous.
Oh.
Have I been able to come out here this whole time?
What is this for?
We still don't know.
Okay.
Let's try calling...
What's his name?
I suppose...
Logan.
Logan speaking.
Oh.
Were you able to find a copy of the book?
I did.
But before I send it, I need to ask you another favor.
I want to get Bess a present.
Oh my god.
She said she was looking for the perfect outfit.
I think that'd be a great gift, but I have no clue what to do in a clothing store.
I sort of just freeze at the sight of hangers.
I think it's genetic.
This guy...
I'll see what I can do.
I know of a program that might be just the thing.
Great.
Thanks.
No.
No way.
Bye.
Am I gonna go...
What?
Oh god.
We got spooky...
It's spooky music time.
I'll be back.
I'm going to Yumi's place.
She's in Kurume.
But before that, maybe we go to...
Matsue.
Let's try and get another piece of the puzzle.
Like, I think we have to help her with the bento.
To get the...
More outfits or something.
Hello.
I'm ready to help with more bento.
Okay.
Okay, this was kind of confusing.
Okay, let's try and remember.
Ouch.
Um...
Oh boy.
Okay.
Food sudoku.
Right.
I'm gonna be real.
It's still confusing.
The only thing that...
The thing that makes it the most confusing...
Is not knowing where...
Like, I wish they put, like, one thing for sure.
You know what I mean?
I think that would be a huge help.
But they just...
They just say...
Good luck to you.
Food dooku.
Yes.
So, I feel that...
The only way we can do this...
Is have the L...
Here.
And then the square here, no?
Yeah, otherwise...
Wait.
Yeah.
Otherwise it won't fit.
So, these two are rice.
So, this is...
Perhaps a piggy...
Piggy egg.
And piggy sandwich.
And a sandwich.
Perhaps.
Yeah.
I'm trying to think...
Like, you can't put this anywhere else...
Where it would make the...
Where it would work with the square.
Because otherwise it would...
Wait.
Hold on.
If you put it here...
Yeah.
It wouldn't...
Wait.
Yeah.
It wouldn't work.
What's the graph on the right mean?
Okay.
So...
I think I might be able to...
Explain it.
So...
These all show...
Different patterns that are in here.
And then...
This means like pig sandwich.
So, that's what this is.
The piggy sandwich.
And piggy egg.
And then...
Whatever is here is a sandwich.
But we don't know what kind of critter it is.
So...
That's basically...
What it means.
What if we had...
What if we had here...
Bear rice.
And then this would be...
This could be bear egg.
And then we cat cat.
And so it would be cat something.
But then cat sandwich on the bottom.
Oh, no.
We can't.
Oh.
Oh, yes we can.
Oh, no.
We can't.
Ah!
No.
We can't do that.
Because this gotta be...
This has to...
Wait.
One of these has to be...
Sandwich.
Oh, wait.
How?
What?
Huh?
Okay.
So this has to be...
Rice.
Sandwich.
Oh, but then...
Ah!
Okay.
The dilemma is...
Wait.
It can work.
With this...
With the...
With the square.
See?
Or...
So this can be the square.
And then this can be the L.
Because the sandwich, sandwich.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I think that works better.
So this is sandwich, sandwich.
So, rice, rice.
Uh...
Now, which side would be the...
Bear, cat, cat?
Bear, eggy.
Would it be right or left?
So the two by two block is in the upper left.
I suppose...
Does this...
I wonder if this egg can overlap with the bear egg.
You know what I mean?
So it would be bear, rice, here.
And then bear, eggy, there.
You know?
It can?
Ah!
Okay, okay.
And then cat, cat.
And then cat.
So cat sandwiched here.
And then a cat something.
And then this would be...
Oh wait.
Uh, piggy.
Piggy.
So this is...
Rice, rice, sandwich, sandwich.
So rice, rice, sandwich.
Bear.
And this matches the pig and the bear.
And then...
Uh...
Okay, now we just need to figure out.
Let's see.
Let's just put him in.
What did I do wrong?
Oh!
What's wrong?
Oh no!
Oh, I got the...
Oh!
I did the square wrong.
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
Okay.
So it has to be...
Okay, hold on.
Ah!
Oh!
Okay, sandwich here.
Bear, egg.
Here.
Other sandwich could be...
Bear sandwich.
Switch.
Here.
But then, how do we do the bear rice egg?
That's so confusing.
No, yeah, you can't rotate it.
So, rice bear would be bottom right.
Oh!
Yeah, because this is a piggy egg, you're right.
Yes, yes, yes.
Then I think this would be piggy here, because it's a pig bear.
And then, yes, rice, egg.
Phew, it's busy here today.
Fantastic.
Are you going to give me anything for it?
Have Miwako and Rantaro been dating long?
It's hard to backdate that sort of thing.
So, let's just say they've been dating somewhere between two and a thousand years.
Is it just me, or do things seem a little strained between Miwako and Rantaro?
Do they?
Come on, make with the detairs.
Ooh, I don't really know.
It's just an impression.
Ugh, boring.
Nancy, if we're going to be gossip buddies, you're going to have to work on your follow-through.
Miwako seems a little annoyed with Rantaro.
Well, that's not surprising.
Rantaro is super annoying.
Super, super annoying.
It's part of this reverse psychology bizarre charm he's got.
When he's in one of his hyper Rantaro moods, it's like hanging out with a puppy.
Except Rantaro is housebroken, and he doesn't go all crazy when there's a cat outside.
Well, most times he doesn't.
Okay.
Um...
Oh my goodness.
Okay, there's so many things.
I got that picture you sent.
Is she going to talk about pretty good?
Oh, the designs.
I did it at the Purikura booth.
They're everywhere around here.
They're these picture booths, and you get to choose decorations, and you can write out your own messages.
Oh, that sounds...
I don't get it.
There's not much to get.
It's just for fun.
Some people use them like notes or something, but...
Mosturi.
It's just something to do when you're out with friends.
Oh, Yumi.
Okay, I'm going to save before we talk about what happened to the mom, just in case we die.
The article about what happened to your mother.
I'm busy.
Maybe you should go.
It said that you were the first one to find her.
That must have been very hard.
I said I'm busy.
That means leave me alone.
Now.
Nancy!
Oh my god.
Can you come back in a bit?
Oh, we made her mad.
Okay.
Nancy Drew.
Good lord.
We gotta find clothes?
Maybe if we go to...
Maybe let's go to Yumi's house and raid her closet.
Kawakaze!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Let's raid her closet.
Maybe that will be...
What we need.
Maybe?
Nancy die.
I need to translate that.
Oh yeah, that's right.
We gotta make the avatar.
Thank you.
Thank you for reminding me.
Which one do you think she would like?
What was the phone number?
Savannah.
404...
555...
4478.
Which one...
Maybe we'll just send it...
What was it?
404-555...
I can't remember this.
4478.
Okay.
Alright.
We didn't get any new outfits or anything.
So...
We're fine.
Okay.
Oh, I think he liked it.
Thanks, Nancy!
You are so welcome.
And Bess, I'm so sorry.
Bess, I'm really sorry.
Logan, you are so welcome.
Ivan, welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
Does that mean he sent the book?
I sure hope so.
Oh, I can't talk to him here.
It's almost twi- It's almost midnight.
I'm gonna call him anyway, because Nancy Drew knows no boundaries.
I'm gonna call him.
Nancy, I got the picture you sent.
I'm going to take it to that boutique she mentioned, and let them do whatever it is they do.
Good.
So you'll be sending the book?
Yeah.
I was thinking I'd give it to Bess, like, hey, here's that book you want, and since I'm here, let's get dinner, and I got you a present.
Oh.
Whatever works.
But the sooner I get that book, the better.
Talk to you later.
I'll talk to you later.
Bye.
Alright, Nancy Drew goes to sleep.
In our haunted, haunted room.
Alright.
Let's set an alarm for...
7pm?
I don't think there's anything else I can do.
I don't know.
I can't get into the room.
I feel... I feel a little stuck.
Besides...
Just... the things...
It's really late.
I should get to bed.
Besides like this... the one thing with the book.
You know?
7pm?
Yeah, we have to set it to PM because Nancy works in the mornings.
And she won't let you set an alarm for it.
Oh!
Moshi Moshi.
We didn't... we didn't get our alarm.
Nancy, we've got the book.
Great!
So when do we see you?
We'll give you the book.
Well, I'm a little wrapped up right now.
George, did we have a friend named Nancy Drew once?
I think so.
Hard to say.
The name sounds familiar.
Was she the one with the magnifying glass or something?
Hey!
Just teasing.
We'll send you the book.
The faster you solve the mystery, the faster the three of us get to hit the town.
Yeah.
Thanks.
You know I can't wait.
No problem.
Anything else?
So, Bess, what's the story with you and Logan?
We're gonna get the tea?
The tea?
Well, he asked me out on a date.
See what I put up with for you?
Such a liar!
Oh?
Nancy, she's such a liar!
Is she being tsundere?
What is she talking about?
She looked like an anime character with the big eyes.
We're going out again as soon as he's done researching the expo for Savannah.
Oh my god!
So, maybe you could put in a word with her about giving her assistant a break?
I'll see what I can do.
Wow.
Okay.
I'll stop bugging you now.
Bye!
I still feel like we have so much left to do in this game.
And I really want to beat it today.
I don't know if that's gonna happen.
I really wanted to beat it today!
We'll see.
Oh, whoops.
Uh...
Hi!
I'll let you go.
Nevermind.
See you later.
Um...
Okay, things we got in our inventory.
We have the key to Yumi's apartment.
The magnetic key.
Maybe something with that.
Uh...
Hmm...
Oh...
The comic book.
Let's go talk with Grandma.
Grandma.
Oh, whoops.
Hello, Nancy-san.
Did you rewrite my name in red ink?
What do you mean?
The name scroll in my room.
It's red now.
Yeah, very ominous.
It's...
It's nothing to worry about.
I'll have it removed.
Uh...
Isn't it a bad omen to have your name written in red?
Yeah, someone's trying to curse me.
Just don't worry about it.
It is nothing.
Can I help you with anything else?
I'll let you get back to work.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, Grandma.
Grandma Mal.
Mm-hmm.
Okay, let's go talk to everybody that we can, I suppose.
Wait.
Oh, sorry.
I thought it had something on...
on it.
But no...
It does not.
Hey.
Oh, never mind.
I'll let you get back to work.
Okay, I guess let's go talk to Yumi again.
Bye.
Let's go talk to Yumi.
Can I talk to her from the phone?
Do I have to go all the way to her place?
Can I ask her everything on the phone?
Oh my god!
Not here.
Bye.
Not in.
Bye-bye.
What was it?
Kure?
Things that...
Oh, no.
That's Pachinko.
It is...
Matsue.
Goodbye.
Bink.
Bink, bink, bink.
Hello.
Do you see Rantaro much?
Oh, yeah.
He loves the city.
He's here every chance he can get.
Aha.
Do you know why he's so eager to move to the city?
Oh, he's been that way forever.
When we were kids, he and I used to jump on the train the second my mom turned her back.
We weren't supposed to go into the city unsupervised.
So, miss, I'd rather break a bone than Arura Miwako never came.
Ordo.
Maybe she was right about that.
We got in so much trouble every time.
I see.
Do you believe that the Ria Khan is haunted?
I do.
It's not just haunted.
There's something else strange going on there.
What do you mean?
Look.
I don't want to freak you out.
But between you and me, the haunting is nothing compared to some of the other strange stuff going on over there.
Last time I visited, it was Rait at night.
And I was out in the garden and something was off.
I could just fear it.
Oh?
All of a sudden, there was this loud shriek.
And this thrash of right.
Oh?
And then, Nancy Drew, I saw aliens.
Oh.
Dozens of them.
They had come to visit Arura of their ghost friends.
Oh.
Okay, I get it.
You don't believe in haunting.
Wasting my time, Yumi.
I didn't even don't.
Sorry.
How would you rate the haunting?
It's a pretty solid haunting, yeah.
Your mother...
I told you I didn't want to talk about that.
Nancy!
Nancy, you're ruining...
Okay, phew.
Do you know what Rintaro wants to do once he moves to Kyoto?
Tech something?
I sort of don't listen to him when he's being boring about things.
Okay.
Alright.
We've talked to her with everything.
I kind of want to do another bento.
I'm ready to help with more bento.
These ones are actually kind of fun.
I'm not gonna lie...
Oh, wow!
Wait, what?
Okay, wow!
This is like the most complex one we've gotten.
And...
Wow!
So middle...
Is cat rice.
Okay.
This shouldn't be so bad, actually.
Probably.
Maybe...
I guess.
Um...
Maybe this is cat egg.
And then...
Rice bunny bunny.
So bear rice...
Bunny sandwich.
Um...
Bunny something.
Maybe...
Uh...
Do-do-do-do-do-do.
Maybe cat sandwich.
Bear...
This has gotta be egg bunny maybe.
No, wait, I messed up.
Oh.
I don't know.
Ah!
Bunny egg.
Wait, which one's gotta be bunny egg?
I still don't get this puzzle.
I get it, but it takes a second.
It does take a second.
Bottom left is bunny egg.
How do you know?
Oh, bunny bunny.
Wait.
Oh, because the bunny bunny.
This or the egg egg.
Sorry, not bunny bunny.
Eggie eggie.
Unless this is the eggie eggie.
This could switch.
Perhaps.
Oops.
This could switch, maybe.
I'll have a hint with the two eggs.
Yeah.
Because it could either be these two or these two.
And then this would be bear, rice, bunny bunny.
And then bear, rabbit.
And then, ugh.
But this one.
This one I don't know.
Oh, wait.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, oh, oh, oh, oh, ah, bear.
Bear.
I don't know.
Ew.
I don't quite understand it, but I did it.
I don't understand it, but I did it.
Please give me things.
Okay.
Never mind.
One more.
One more, one more.
One more, one more, one more.
Are these... these are separate?
Or... these are all... okay.
Oh, this one's confusing.
Oh, gosh.
I'm into working for free.
I know!
Okay, nevermind.
I'll stop bugging you now.
Okay, see ya!
Wasted too much time on puzzles.
But...
Maybe when we get back to...
the hotel, we'll have the book, finally.
Maybe we just needed to leave for a bit.
Can we have a nonogram as a treat?
Did I do all of them?
I have a delivery for you.
Nice!
Here!
Thank you!
Awesome.
Do you remember anything about Savannah, the paranormal author?
That was a long time ago.
Not really.
She must have been here for a while if she was writing about the ryokan.
You don't remember anything?
I remember that she asked too many insensitive questions.
I was happy to see her go.
This just sounds...
Sounds...
I'll let you get back to work.
You think Miwako hates us?
Uh-oh.
Uh... this one.
Bess.
Usually I bring flowers on a first date.
But this time I brought a creepy book about ghosts.
I hope your friend wasn't kidding about you wanting this book.
Because otherwise this date will probably be weird for the both of us, Logan.
Alright.
Chapter 6.
The Ryokan Hiei.
Japan to a girl who grew up barefoot on the French porch...
Fr...
Front...
Front porch of a creaky old house in Savannah.
It's just about the most exotic place there is on earth.
Sometimes in the middle of a stormy night when the wind is whistling and the tree branches are scratching at the windows, I feel like I am back at the Ryokan...
The Ryokan Hiei.
Stop!
I didn't say French porch!
On those nights, I often wish I had never visited that charming looking inn on the outskirts of Kyoto.
The second I stepped inside the Ryokan's gate, I suddenly understood why I had been called in.
For those of you who have never been in a haunted place, the feeling is unmistakable.
Imagine the sensation of taking a rickety rollercoaster through a dense fog.
Now multiply that by tenfold.
Do note, she just said she grew up on the front porch.
Hm?
What's wrong with that?
The atmosphere inside the Ryokan, however, was even thicker.
The inn was washed in an unearthly sense of cold that the fire pit in the lobby couldn't touch.
Or it was winter.
The whole structure radiated uncertainty and dread.
Something terrible lived there.
The inn was, and still is, run by a truly wonderful family.
Takai and her grandmother, Miwako...
Oh, sorry.
Takai and her granddaughter, Miwako, took excellent care of Logan and I.
But were both extremely tight-lipped about the history of the Ryokan.
A neighbor boy, Rintarno.
Rintarno.
Oh, I know.
I was shook.
There's Rintarno over there.
Rintarno over there.
No wonder he's so bitter about it.
No wonder he wants to leave.
Rintarno was able to shed a little light on the situation.
The innkeeper's daughter, Kasumi, had recently died under mysterious circumstances.
Ever since her death, the inn began to change rapidly for the worse.
Takai had begun to worry about her daughter's yurei.
Worry that her daughter's yurei was haunting Ryokan.
I set up my equipment right away.
Luckily, I had my entire EVP kit at the ready.
Ahem.
EVP, or electronic voice phenomenon, is a process of recording ambient room noise using very sensitive microphones in hopes of capturing the sounds of the spirit world that are too quiet to hear unaided.
EVP equipment can also be beneficial to debunk false hauntings, as it often picks up conversations and other telltale signs of trickery.
Super excited to hear you want to get into Gundam!
Watch the OG series for Max Brain Rot, as the whole franchise has OG Brain Rot, and it's my V-Day.
One minute hero, happy birthday!
Yeah, I...
I wanted to start at the beginning.
Is that how we hear you speak?
Yeah, pretty much, yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Yes, yes, yes.
I placed the microphones in place- in places where I felt the greatest disturbances.
By the fire pit in the lobby.
Behind the old cherry tree in the gardens.
By both baths, and in the upstairs hallways.
Uh, sound travels very well in the old ryokan.
So my equipment- Uh-huh.
Sorry.
Uh-huh.
My equipment picked up more conversations than usual, but nothing supernatural.
At 2am, however, that all changed.
The lights in my room suddenly flickered and cut off!
EVP catching that ghostly ASMR.
I rushed downstairs to my recorders.
I couldn't hear a thing.
But the readings were off the charts.
Before I could listen to the audio, I saw her.
Pale and thin.
With long black hair.
Dripping muddy water.
Moving through the shadows.
Despite my experience...
I froze as she slipped out of sight.
I stood there in the lobby until the sun finally came up.
Half hoping she would reappear.
The other half desperately hoping to never see her again.
Takai woke me up that afternoon.
We had to leave.
Kasumi said- Oh, Kasumi, she said, had changed her mind.
Whatever faith Takai had in me the day before was now gone.
I doubt I was the only one to see the ghost the night before.
I gave her my card and told her to call me if she ever changes her mind.
I doubt she will and I have to admit I'm a little relieved.
This is... this is all that she wrote about this place?
On the bus to the temple the next morning I reviewed the EVP tapes.
What I heard sounded like a hundred voices repeating a single word in Japanese.
I pulled out my transliterated...
Phrase book.
Your dictionary?
Hahaha.
The word simply meant...
Leave.
That's the kind of message you only want to hear once you're gone.
I still sometimes worry about the Shimizu family.
I can't help but wonder...
What it must be like for them during those long nights...
When the woman I saw in the shadows is awake.
She pulled out the Duolingo for that.
The ghosts of Centralia, PA.
Ghost towns.
Oh, cool.
Okay, so we read that.
Hello.
I'll let you go.
Bye.
Okay, we still got time.
We can go talk to Grandma.
Probably be like... Did you notice... Did you notice Miwako while I was changing the camera angle?
We probably can talk to her about the book.
Hello, Nancy-san.
Really?
Nothing?
I'll talk to you later.
Goodbye.
Talk to Rentaro.
Yeah, we'll go talk to... Go talk to everybody, I guess.
Oh, I didn't... I was like, why can't I leave?
Hey.
Oh.
Have you ever heard of EVP?
Electronic voice phenomenon?
That whole...
If you go to haunted places and record the ambient noise, when you turn it way up, you'll hear things that are too quiet for the human ear.
Ghosts, specters, all sorts of baddies.
Baddies?
I'm a baddie.
Rentaro.
Savannah mentioned it in her book.
I wonder if you know how I could try it out.
Oh?
Oh, sure.
I got something that can do that.
Oh?
I've got a bunch of little recorders, actually.
I'm trying to find the right one to record new sounds for the Rentaro 4000.
Oh!
Here you go.
Thank you.
Thanks.
All you have to do is hook it up to the speakers over there.
Okay.
I have a program that edits out dead audio.
Get it?
It'll cut right to the parts that actually have recorded sound.
Oh, okay.
Oh, and once I've got it fixed, you have to check out the new recorder.
I saw the reverse tension near the little.
Okay.
What's it do?
This guy's such a nerd.
It's awesome.
High data wireless transfer.
Here's something you like, just push a button.
It zips it to your computer.
If you want to send everyone a message, you just speak into it, push send all, and it shoots what you've recorded to everyone's voicemail inbox.
Very, very cool.
I just got to keep fussing with it.
That sounds really horrible and annoying.
The wireless transfer sounds nice.
I think sending it to everybody sounds really terrible.
Very, very cool.
Have you read Savannah's book?
Yeah.
She spelled my name wrong.
She's not a good speller.
Maybe she's being haunted by the ghost of a sparing.
Do you think there's anything to what it says?
I remember when she was here.
She was very...
She has this way of looking at you.
It's like she knows if you're telling her the truth or not.
I'm glad she's back into regular journalism instead of this ghost nonsense.
It really seemed to take its toll on her.
I thought it was just a typo.
Like the game mid.
Not that I'm saying she can communicate with ghosts.
That's so funny.
But she really believes in all of that.
And watching her, the way she'd walk around here in these half-terrified days, it made you worry about her.
If you don't believe in ghosts, why did you worry?
Because believing in something, that makes it real to you.
To her, that whole other world is real.
And that is still a very dangerous thing.
A ghost doesn't need to be real to haunt you.
Wow.
That feels so deep.
Just joining in as Idaokojima.
Maybe.
Yumi said that you want to move to the city.
That's so deep.
Well, yeah.
I mean, given the choice, everyone wants to live in the city.
I don't think so.
The country is fine.
The mountains are great.
But you look at one, and you pretty much got it figured out.
It's big.
It's rocky.
It's a mountain.
Case closed.
What?
But the city is interesting and quirky.
The writers are pretty good at writing weird guys.
Yeah.
What do you want to do in Kyoto?
I think it's the opposite, though.
I wanted to work in the tech sector.
Once you see a city, you pretty much know all cities.
Everything's moving so fast.
And in 10 years, I can't even imagine.
And you've got to be there to be a part of it.
Why doesn't Miwaka want to move into the city?
Your guess is as good as mine.
I've been trying to figure that one out for a long time.
Hey!
Considering everything that's happened here, why would anyone want to stay?
What do you mean?
Oh.
He just shrugs.
Okay.
I'll let you get back to work.
See you later.
Okay.
Now we have our recorder.
So I think we got to go to the places that are written here, no?
So, let's see.
I placed it in the fire pit in the lobby.
Let's go to that first.
Okay.
Fire pit by the lobby.
Turn around, please.
Please.
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
Oh, at 2 a.m.
You're right.
Let's go to sleep.
Oh no, that's going to be so scary!
That's going to be so scary, no?
Okay.
Yeehaw, jump scare.
I know it gets me too.
Alright, 2.
Oh boy, 2 a.m.
Oh god.
My alarm is so...
Upstairs hallways.
I guess we could do it right here.
Can't record there.
It's full.
Delete.
When do I stop?
Okay.
That's one.
What did we get?
Scary.
Oh god.
I'm scared.
She mentioned both baths.
Are there two baths?
There's actually... No, that's a good point.
There's only one.
She's, uh... misinformed?
The music stopping scares me even more, I think, than when it's around.
Oh, gosh.
Why does it do this every time?
God, that beep is so loud.
Recording, recording, recording.
Or they're hiding a bath somewhere.
Do you think the bath where she died in is being hidden?
Maybe.
Maybe they did used to have two baths.
One for women, one for men.
And they sealed off the one where she died.
Freaky!
Okay, um...
Behind the old cherry tree.
So, cherry... Okay, we got the fire pit.
Both baths.
Upstairs hallways.
Cherry tree.
Was I not just here?
Trying this out?
And it didn't work?
Oh, see?
Yeah, it didn't work.
Delete.
Is this close enough?
To the cherry tree?
No?
Okay.
Oh my god, it's so loud.
The peepo?
Behind it.
There's no way I can get behind it.
There's no way.
I'm gonna turn the sound down since it's so loud.
Tuhuhuh.
Ah.
It doesn't work.
One of the peepo.
Let's go to the peepo.
To the peepo!
Do I have to open it back up?
To the peepo.
You think?
Oh!
It's working!
I wonder what it's saying.
Probably like...
Kyuh!
Etsy!
Get out of here!
Calm.
Hentai.
Let's go to the other hallway, I suppose.
Because it said upstairs hallways.
So we can go here.
Nope.
Just kidding.
Here.
We gotta go deep in.
Unless...
Unless the first one counted.
Oh, sorry.
Haha.
Fire pit.
Behind the old cherry tree.
By both baths.
And in the upstairs hallways.
Maybe like closer down.
No?
Did you do one at the footprints?
No.
But it's...
That's not in the book.
I guess we can try in my room.
Oh, that's too scary.
Doing one in your own room?
Hell no.
Hahaha.
Uh...
Nope.
I can't tell if I've done it all or not.
Maybe...
I don't think this counts as behind the cherry blossom tree, but...
Nope.
Can you bless me a minute for my exam today?
What?
Hearu, you got this!
You got this!
What is this?
Minto Energy Beam!
I don't know.
I feel like I'm doing it correctly, but it's not... I don't know.
Is it because it's not 2am?
Oh, maybe because it's 3am now.
No way.
They wouldn't make it that...
that, like, strict, would they?
No way.
Hold on.
I'm gonna find... I'm gonna read the walkthrough for this part.
Oh, EVP.
Ah!
That's how you go behind.
Let's see if it works now.
Ah!
Okay.
Wow.
The ghost had so much to say.
Okay, okay, hold on.
Um, let's see.
Go to the places mentioned in Savannah's book and record the sounds.
The places are behind the cherry tree, this fireplace.
Mirror in the bath.
The sha- by the showers.
And both upstairs corridors sort of halfway down.
But I...
I only got the one upstairs, no?
I didn't get the other upstairs.
I think we got outside the...
the door...
of the bath.
So maybe that's okay.
Unless it counted as, like, both hallways, you know?
Yeah, see?
Oh!
I should check that out.
Okay.
I should go back and play this at Rentaro's place.
Oh!
Okay.
Uh, I guess we're good then.
Cool.
We're gonna play it on the spe- We're gonna play it on the speaker?
Oh my god, that's so scary.
I love how this is Rentaro's place.
It's literally a shack.
Like...
There's a speaker here.
Oh god, I'm scared.
Play.
Oh.
Oh god, it's so loud.
That was just static.
Hold on.
Every time I...
press the thing, I...
lower the volume.
Also just static?
Okay.
That's...
someone playing football.
And then...
You can't just do that.
We're not all here to make sure that you get what you want, Yumi.
No.
Don't stop.
Please continue with your speech.
Uh oh.
I love jumping on the train to get picked on by you two.
The drama?
Couldn't think of a better way to spend my day.
Can't wait for the mean phone messages about what an awful sister I am because I never visit.
You've got to be selfish about this too.
Everything's always about you.
She asked one thing from you and you act like it's the end of the world.
Oh, shut up, Miwako.
When you're both ganging up on me, then it actually is about me.
Thanks to Brat.
Brat?
You wanna see Brat?
I'll show you Brat.
It looks a lot like this.
I can't believe you just did that.
Believe it.
I'm out.
It sounds like she threw something in the pond.
I should check that out.
Okay.
That's what it sounded like?
In the pond.
Like over here?
Oh, I can go up to here.
Oh!
I can go up to this.
Uh, wait.
Can I check in the pond?
I'm in the pond.
Don't call it a shack.
That's Rintarno's doghouse.
Uh, maybe on the bridge?
How do we record this?
When did they...
When did she...
Wait.
So I was behind the tree.
And they were arguing in front of the tree.
And...
Then she threw it in just...
Now?
I'm so confused.
Huh?
The logic here...
Is escaping me a little bit.
Huh?
How am I supposed to...
I don't...
Huh?
What am I doing wrong?
What am I doing wrong here?
Try the other side.
Uh...
I don't think I can get close.
Oh, wait!
Oh, that's a deer scare.
There.
Do you guys feel relaxed?
That's such a nice detail, actually.
It's actually kind of such a nice detail.
Um...
Oh, wait here?
Uh, can I turn?
Uh...
No.
Please, let me search.
Please, let me search the pond!
Please!
What?
Oh!
Wait!
Ah!
Eighteen.
What's that?
Looks like there are some rocks missing.
I wonder if I could find them around the garden.
What the hell is this?
Wait, what is this?
What is this?
This doesn't fit in any of them.
What?
Okay, fine.
We're gonna go find some...
rocks around the garden.
Okay.
Uh...
No!
That's it!
We were so close!
Oh my gosh, we barely made that then.
Holy cow.
We're barely...
Barely made that.
Oh my gosh.
Is there any homework we gotta grid?
Oh!
On the farm!
Just ordered my...
Thank you, Jalen!
The pig goes quack.
My family likes to hunt in the hay.
The sheep eats hay.
Yeah.
Do sheep eat hay?
A lamb is a baby horse.
No.
The duck goes quack.
Yes.
My cat likes to hunt in the barn.
Okay.
The hay eats horse.
Oh no!
A sheep is a baby lamb.
No.
Fumiko.
The duck goes quack.
Our genius here.
My cat likes to hunt in the barn.
The horse eats hay.
Hay.
A lamb is a baby sheep.
Genius, genius, Fumiko.
Quack.
The cat goes quack.
No.
My lamb likes to hunt in the hay.
The duck eats barn.
Cyndal!
Happy birthday!
Thank you so much!
Happy, happy birthday!
A sheep is a baby horse.
No.
But you get points for making me laugh.
The duck goes quack.
Oh my gosh, there's...
My cat lights...
Wait, they're so close!
The horse eats hay.
A sheep is a baby lamb.
So close!
So close.
So close, Takeo.
Alright.
We did all of our grading.
Um, what did we get?
Oh, we got the key for 18.
So let's go...
Downstairs.
Would that be in here?
Oh, this is one.
Locked.
No, don't turn around.
Turn around.
I believe it's...
10.
19.
Oh, it's the room!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, but she... I didn't need it anyway.
Hello, Nancy-san.
Okay, now we can come here and die!
I should go.
I'll talk to you later.
Oh my gosh.
Goodbye, Nancy-san.
Progress, progress, progress.
Progress!
Ah!
Okay.
So we got that, and we have to go look for rocks in the...
Hi.
Was Yumi here earlier?
Yes.
Really?
I'm sorry I missed her.
Don't be.
Anyway, it's always Blink and you'll miss her with Yumi.
You'd think she was allergic to this place.
Which is fine by me.
Why is that?
Hi.
Look, I know she's fun at first.
But it's like strangers get fun Yumi, and all we get is touchy, angry Yumi these days.
Oh.
What do you think that is?
God, maybe you and Red Taro are made for each other.
I'll talk to you later.
Okay, see ya.
Maybe you guys are meant for each other.
Alright, let's find some rocks.
Um...
How do we find some rocks?
Here?
There's a rock?
There's a rock, rock, rock.
How do I search for the rocks?
Maybe let's go to the deer scare.
Any rocks in here?
Any rocks?
Oh, sorry.
Rantarno.
So true.
Nothing.
That's a rock fact.
Oh, my bad.
I'll turn around.
Maybe he knows where I can find the rocks.
Hello?
Nope.
I'll talk to you later.
Bye.
He knows literally nothing.
Useless to me.
Useless.
Wait!
Wait.
I found a rock!
Okay, okay.
That's one.
How many do we need?
How do we know what rocks are the ones that we're trying to find?
Oh!
Second rock?
Okay.
Okay, okay.
So far, so good.
How many do we need?
Who knows?
Another rock.
I'm sure she'll say something like, okay, I have all I need, right?
Off to a rocky start.
Hmm.
Maybe...
Splash exam.
Where's the...
Where's the rock thing that...
Where's the thing that we're supposed to be...
Like, investigating?
Where's that thing?
Where is...
I hope nobody notices that I'm wandering...
Oh, here we go.
What...
Do these mean?
What?
What do they mean?
The bases.
It belongs in a museum.
One, two, three, four.
One, two, three, four, five.
Wait.
I can't tell how many I need.
Oh, see?
Like, there's that one that's really tiny.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Oh, we need a lot.
I think?
Because it mirrors the music rising.
Yeah, it's just...
It does that.
It's just the ambiance.
Don't worry about it.
There's, like, one more I think we need?
Maybe?
Where could it be, though?
Maybe on this side?
No?
Turn around?
Around here?
No?
On this side?
The lantern?
Oh, yeah.
Let's go check the lantern again.
So true.
Wait.
Oh, no.
That's a reflection.
Uh...
No?
I don't know quite what we can do with this.
Oh, wait!
Ah!
Perfect!
Alright!
Good job, guys!
Good job, team!
Damn!
Yeah!
Oh, my gosh!
Naruto!
Sakura!
The beautiful!
Oh, gosh.
Um...
What do they...
Is this something I can brute force?
Or...
Okay.
Oh, so this is the...
This one has a...
Tiny bottom?
You can't brute force.
There's a book in the lobby.
Okay.
Counselor Chip, you are our...
Savior.
Thank you.
Which book is it?
Uh...
I think there's one over here.
Yes.
Ah!
Okay.
I think I skipped this earlier.
Last time, I mean.
Reishoseki.
The soul stone.
Low vertical stone.
Wide base, tapered top.
Upright stone.
Taitoseki.
Tall vertical stone.
Only slightly bigger at the base than the top.
Is the tallest stone...
Oh, gosh.
How am I supposed to remember all this?
Shintaiseki.
The flat stone is similar in appearance to a stepping stone.
I'm taking notes?
Okay, everybody take notes.
I don't have any pen or paper.
Have I screenshot it, you guys?
I have to, like, close...
I have to, like...
Get out of the game.
So it doesn't really help me.
Shigyoseki.
The arching stone is the only stone with...
Okay, so...
I can probably remember the heart one.
The arching stone is a flat stone.
To a...
Similar to a stepping stone.
Reclining stone.
Neither has low...
Neither has low as the heart stone nor as tall...
As the branching stone.
Arching stone.
Only stone with a flat top wider than its base.
Alright.
Use a phone!
Oh my gosh, you're so true.
You're so right.
Take a picture with my phone.
Haha, okay.
Perfect.
Oop.
Now we're good to go, baby.
Oops.
I saw someone say there's a face in the water.
Where?
I don't see anything.
Where's a face in the water?
Okay.
What?
No, I said why I can't...
I already said why I can't screen share, you guys.
Okay.
Soul stone.
Low vertical...
Stone.
Wide base and tapered top.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
Like...
This or this?
Um...
Heart stone is flat and is like a skipping stone.
So I imagine it's that one.
Arching stone.
Only stone with a flat top wider than its base.
So this one is the branching stone.
Face bottom right.
There's a hundred percent of face in the water.
What?
Um...
Ox stone.
Reclining stone.
Maybe this one.
Is this reclining?
It's kind of like a...
Leaning back.
Uh...
Vertical...
Low vertical stone.
Wide base, tapered top.
This is the soul stone.
Oh!
Hmm...
Strange.
I've seen those markings before.
Origami!
Oh!
Wait.
The origami book in Takai's room would be helpful right about now.
Dear Marianne.
Thank you for your last letter.
It could not have come at a better time.
My mother is making me crazy!
We're beyond busy here with the festival.
And she wants to fire half of the staff.
Correction.
She has fired half of the staff.
If I ever become a weird perfectionist, smack me silly!
Yumi's birthday was yesterday.
Awww...
And not surprisingly, there was drama.
At dinner, my mother asked if she was ready to start learning how to run the ryokan.
And this led to a fight.
Everything is a sore subject with that girl these days.
This puberty.
But lately, mentioning her running the ryokan is pretty much just picking a fight.
I remember what it was like to be her age.
Wanting to see the world, but I never hated it here.
I don't get it.
I have to get back to work.
Keigu.
Kasumi.
I wonder if it makes a message when you fold it.
Yeah, that's what I'm curious about too.
Where's the face in the water?
That?
Looks like Otacon.
Where's the face in the water?
Where?
That looks like a skull.
Frog.
If there is one, I don't see it.
Me neither.
I bought your merch, but I didn't use the coupon boomer.
I'm ashamed, but without the free shipping code, it doubles the price.
No, no, no, no.
Don't wait.
I would much rather you save money than use my code.
Thank you.
My mom used to buy them for $2 at the supermarket.
This game is long.
This game is hella long.
I don't see a face.
I think I'm getting gas lit.
Okay.
To the Orog Army room.
Oops.
Okay.
Orog Army, Orog Army.
Wrong.
Okay.
I should wait until Takai is gone before doing this.
What?
Go to bed, Grandma.
What time is it?
Nine.
Almost nine.
I think it says it's...
Hello, Nancy-san.
I'll let you go.
Come again.
I think it said until 10 p.m.
Can I sleep until 10?
10.30.
Okay.
Let's go sleep until 10.30.
Because then we can also get the...
The...
What's it called?
The kettle.
Oh.
But yeah, this game is crazy long.
10...
30.
Do do do.
Do du du.
Do.
Do du du du.
Do du du.
Okay.
Um...
Sneaking Mission?
Good.
She's gone.
Yes!
Yes.
She left something.
Oh.
Oh!
Wow, grandma is so careless.
Holy cow!
Oh my gosh, I feel like we're making such great progress all of a sudden, you know?
Finally!
Oh, and there's a key!
Oh my gosh, we're making like crazy progress all of a sudden.
Okay.
What the hell does that mean?
A valley fold!
Wait.
Yeah, valley fold.
Oh, sure!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for this!
Thank you!
Wait, what do you mean not quite?
Start over?
I just did what?
Mountain fold!
Or is it a crease?
Okay.
Fold... Fold to front?
Fold to front!
Uh...
Ooh...
Ooh, it's just straight.
It's just straight.
I don't think it's a mountain fold.
Another fold to front?
You think so?
Okay.
Uh...
This one...
It's a...
Fold then unfold.
Okay.
Very nice.
Alright, five is...
Floop!
But half.
Fold behind?
Yeah, fold behind.
Fold to...
Back.
I think.
Please say yes.
Oof!
Alright.
Number six.
Uh...
It's a little...
It's a...
Little bend.
What the hell does that mean?
Wait!
It's...
Oh wait!
It's a...
Push invert.
Okay.
This looks like bamboo.
I should search the property for something made out of that.
Ohhhh...
Good job, Nancy-san.
Bamboo.
Bamboo?
She's like, what is Nancy getting into right now?
Hi.
If you didn't work here, what would you do?
I...
Yeah, the deer scare probably.
It's been so long since I've been asked that.
I don't know.
Something very different.
Something exciting.
With Lentaro.
I don't think you like him.
I should go.
I'll talk to you later.
Okay, see ya.
Yeah, the water tipping thing.
Yeah, yeah, I think that's it.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Oh, my bad.
They're like, what is she getting into?
I'm just like...
That looks like the image on the letter.
I'm just like wandering the property.
It looks like I could pry this open if I had the right tool.
Sounds like we need Lentaro to go to sleep.
Are you still in here?
Hey, buddy.
Hi.
What's that wooden thing in the garden?
The tree?
No.
The wooden thing that makes the knocking noise.
Okay, to be fair.
No.
The thing...
I'm teasing.
To be fair, the wooden thing in the garden is not very specific.
What is it?
It uses flowing water to make weird knocking noises that scare away the deer so they don't eat all of the flowers.
Oh, that's neat.
Does it work?
I don't know.
Deer still eat the flowers, but it's hard to tell if they're scared or not.
Or that their expressions pretty much look the same.
Kinda like this.
Oh, don't look at me like that, please.
Oh, God.
So...
Oh, God, leave!
Yeah, let's...
Let's not do that again, Lentaro.
That was frightening.
I didn't like it.
Yeah, he looked exactly like the emoji.
Alright.
Now, let's sleep until 1am.
I don't think Nancy is getting enough sleep at this place.
I...
I worry a bit for her health.
We have her up, like, at all hours of the night.
And then...
She works...
I guess she has to wake up at 4am for work.
And then works until 7am.
And then does more investigating.
Like, damn.
She is crazy.
Okay, we've got several things going on here.
And time is of the essence.
First thing is...
We need to go sneak into Lentaro's place.
And we need...
Probably...
Something...
Here.
The music is getting so crazy.
Ooh!
I don't recognize this.
I feel like the soundtrack is changing.
Ah!
Screw the driver!
That's not my...
Nope.
That is not my first pick, but...
Okay.
There we go.
Screwdriver!
This must have meant something to Kasumi if she went through so much trouble to hide it.
Okay.
Wait.
You don't think...
Is this a nanogram?
Oh my god!
No.
Is it a nanogram?
Oh my god!
Yippee!
Okay.
Now we gotta try and do this one too.
Which...
This thing confuses the heck out of me.
I don't understand...
At all what you're trying to do.
What if I got it first, Troy?
Wait.
The final nanogram...
Nonogram.
Is that even saying nanogram?
It's a nonogram.
I'm stupid.
Sorry.
Turn on all the lights without overlapping.
No!
Oh!
These...
Wait.
There has to be an overlap, no?
Hold on.
There's a manual.
Uh...
Our system uses an 8x8 grid with a unique colored entry code.
Mito.
Hi.
Hello!
Um...
Unique colored entry code designed by the user.
The colors are then split and encoded into five key cards by our team of specialists.
With...
Extra squares on each card for added security.
To open the secured compartment, place the key cards into the slots in the correct...
Layering order and rotate their displays until they match the entry code pattern.
I don't think we know the entry code pattern.
Now that I think about it.
Maybe the code is in the PC.
Oh!
Then...
We gotta...
We could do that.
Um...
You?
Ooh, what if it's...
What if it shows a ghastly face?
I need to hurry before someone catches me.
Yes!
Hurry!
Caught!
I was waiting for you!
Okay.
I need a dictionary to translate that.
Nancy Drew, just read it!
Read the password!
Okay.
Now open it.
Nancy Drew, open it.
Nancy Drew!
What am I supposed to do?
I didn't do it.
Wait, but I clicked on it.
I need to hurry before someone catches me.
Okay.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
It was red when I clicked it.
I swear.
Ooh!
Oh!
I should get the teapot off the fire.
Holy cow.
What did it say?
I missed it.
Wait, what is it?
I need to translate that.
Takakawa.
Okay.
Oops.
Please, let me go in there.
Okay.
Oh, God.
This thing is getting more and more defective.
Defective.
The password I need is in that envelope in the puzzle box.
Ka.
Japanese keyboard.
Where's the wa?
Wa.
Oh!
Room tracker.
Sasaki, Sasaki, Sasaki, Sasaki.
Chan!
We're in, baby.
This is all that's on here.
Williams just left.
What if there was someone that checked in?
Arrived, like, far long ago but never departed.
Looks like this is as far back as the records go.
Okay.
What do I need this for?
Sasaki, Johnny Sasaki.
Hahaha.
Yeah, what does this tell me, actually?
What, what does this...
What was Savannah's last name?
Woodum.
Woodham.
Oh!
Nah!
Inai!
Arifur.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Woodham.
Inai.
She's not there.
Sokolav, where?
No way!
We got Johnny Sasaki and Sokolav still.
Oh my gosh.
Sokolav.
This poor thing.
If this poor cat...
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Well, now we have something to call her about.
This we still...
Need.
I don't know what the pattern is.
And it feels too difficult to brute force.
So...
Okay.
Wait, is that the pattern?
Wait, what do you mean?
I'm looking at the pattern.
Oh, this?
Oh!
That's the pattern?
Huh?
You have to layer it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's just put that in.
This is like...
I don't think it really matters which way I put these in.
Yeah.
Okay.
It doesn't really matter which one goes in where.
Oh, whoops.
Oh.
Okay.
So...
Hold on.
Okay.
Let's just put here.
You.
Wait, what the...
It has to, no?
I wish I could see the pattern.
Without...
What?
Do red first.
Oh, wait.
I think I get it.
Oh!
Ow!
And I can see it if I hover over.
Okay, okay, okay.
So it would probably be...
What's green look like?
No, I...
Oh, wait.
Purple can be...
Like that.
Wait, didn't I get it?
Oh, wait.
Ah!
Wait.
Oh, my God.
I'm so close.
I'm so stinking close.
Uh...
So maybe...
We all just shift these down one.
No.
Oh!
Yeah!
I'm a genius.
To all rooms ending in eight, nine.
Oh, okay.
To open all rooms ending in eight or nine.
Okay.
All right.
Let's go.
Okay.
So now we...
Uh...
Okay.
We got the password.
We got a nonogram thing.
We got...
Rooms...
Key room...
Key to rooms...
Eight or nine.
What's with the music of waiting for Nancy to get stabbed randomly?
No.
She's getting haunted.
Uh...
Um...
How big is Nancy?
She's got a hammer space.
It's as big as she wants it to be.
Okay.
And then we got this mysterious little key.
Which I feel like I saw...
Chest key.
I feel like I saw...
That...
Somewhere.
You think it's...
Um...
Hold on.
Uh...
Is it...
This?
I wonder.
Oh!
Ooh!
Dear Marianne.
You're my best friend.
You've always been.
I want you to know...
That no matter what happens...
You made my life happier.
Safer.
More interesting place.
You have a beautiful family.
You should be very proud of the life you've made.
Is this a...
Okay.
This isn't like a...
Like a...
A note.
That you leave before you leave, right?
You deserve all the happiness in life and I hope it finds you.
I'm in a strange mood these days.
I don't know what's come over me.
I worry.
I worry about just everything.
It's like I can see behind everything.
Like I can see the...
Mechanics that move everything and everyone.
I don't know how to explain it.
It's like I've stepped outside of my life as if...
As I know it.
And no matter how much I try to step back in...
I can't.
I don't fit anymore.
I fit less and less every day.
I'm scared.
Every night I go to bed hoping the feeling will be gone when I wake up.
Oh.
Thank you.
It's so...
It's so big.
And some wire.
Oh.
I can't take that?
Okay.
Some...
What is this?
It's like a copper wire or something?
There's something else behind the note.
No.
I think...
I think it's like...
The note is shoved into the letter and it's torn.
Like that.
I think.
It's really unnerving when there's no music.
I'm gonna save.
Cause I'm scared.
Where'd the music go?
The silence.
Wait.
It's never been gone for this long has...
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Don't scare me.
Okay.
This room ends in nine.
Wait.
Oh, nevermind.
Anything in here?
Any ghosts?
Guys, I might actually end it...
Here though.
I didn't want to finish today, but I think we got a lot more.
Hold on.
I'm gonna look at...
I'm gonna look at the walkthrough and see where we're at and how much longer it shows.
Oh, let's see.
Um...
Oh, wait.
Wait.
I don't think actually there's that much left.
I think...
Oh, wait.
No, there's a couple days.
Oh, no, no, no.
Sorry.
I scrolled a little fast.
I think it might be a bit shorter next stream, but that's okay.
You got at least an hour.
Yeah, I think...
I think at least.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So...
We will...
It's already been four and a half hours anyway.
We will finish this.
Uh...
Mmm...
Dang.
If only I...
If only I didn't...
I would have finished this Saturday.
If I wasn't doing...
Uh...
Half-Life.
Since I moved it then.
Hmm...
Yeah, we made a bunch of progress today.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh...
I'll find the time.
Because I feel like we don't have that much left.
So I'm like, maybe I can just double it up with something else this week.
Hmm...
Maybe instead of the YouTube games, I'd finish it.
That would be tomorrow.
And then I can move the YouTube games to another day.
Hmm...
The YouTube games...
Thanks, Try Princess!
Hmm...
And then I can move those to another day.
And then that would be before...
Doki.
Because I'd like to finish it up.
I thought you were doing Visage...
Visage with...
Tomorrow with Doki too.
Yeah!
I am.
That's why I would do this.
And then...
With Doki.
Yeah, so...
Okay.
Then we will...
Do it tomorrow.
We'll finish the game tomorrow.
Thanks for the stream, Rinto.
Can't wait to see the Nonogram powers in action next stream.
Have a good rest.
Thank you!
Thank you, guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
And...
Yeah...
Austin, Nadia.
Thank you so much for the podcast.
And thank you!
Yes.
We will finish this tomorrow.
Sorry, I'll move the YouTube games to sometime next week.
And...
We will...
Because I really wanted to finish this up today.
But that's okay.
Bye.
That's a-okay.
It will be in the middle of the day.
I apologize, but...
Um...
Yeah!
Did you notice Doki not using the 0-0-0 Ice...
Monkey meta?
I sent her a picture of...
Hold on.
Let me see.
I did save, right?
Let me close the game.
I sent her!
I was like, hey Doki, look at my...
Look at my monkey.
Um...
My monkey setup...
Uh...
I didn't die on this one yet.
I...
Um...
Still working on it.
But she was like, where's Ice Monkey?
I was like, you don't even know this guy.
You don't even know Ice Monkey.
This is...
This is what I was working on earlier.
Oh, but she was playing and I was like...
Okay, I'm gonna take a break and I'm gonna play some...
I'm gonna play some bloons too.
Oh, so that's my...
That was my bloon setup.
I literally can't see anything.
And yeah, Ice Monkey is there.
She's like, where's Ice Monkey?
And I was like, he's chillin'.
He's chillin' up there!
0-0-0 Ice Monkey meta.
It's a...
I can't tell what's going on.
It's a bunch of boats and submarines.
Yeah.
Pretty much.
Okay.
Thank you guys!
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
I'm getting so sleepy now.
So I'm gonna also go to sleep.
I'll see you guys when I see you...
Next time!
What's your next?
Otsumito!
Do I go?
Thank you!
May Sudoku stay far, far away.
Yeah!
I said, hey, why don't you give me the nonograms?
I love nonograms!
And then they're like...
Okay, fine.
We'll give you the nonograms.
And now we'll do it next time.
But I've never done a 15x15, so I'm kind of excited.
And scared.
We'll see how it goes.
Bye!
Oyasumi!
Oyasumito!
Bye-bye!
Thanks for watching!
Thanks for hanging out with me!
Bye-bye!